GOOD MORNING SORRY
THAT WE'RE RUNNING A LITTLE
LATE. BUT IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE
TO. WELCOME LOT OF THE IN
PERSON PERSON THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO DO THAT AND- IF
WE CAN ASK PEOPLE TO BEGIN
TAKING THEIR SEATS AND THE
MEMBERS. SO COME TO THE- DYESS
NOW. GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
FOR ATTENDING THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON CALIFORNIA MEXICO
COOPERATION IN THE VERY
BEAUTIFUL FORTIETH SENATE
DISTRICT MY HOME THE PLACE OF
MY BIRTH THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA IN MY
EYES. I'D LIKE TO FIRST OF ALL
BEGIN BY THINKING IN THE CITY
OF NATIONAL CITY THE MARE THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
MARYLAND SOUND ALIKE ON US THAT
WAS A LEASE AND THE COUNCIL WE
HAVE RUN MARCIN HERE THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE THANK YOU FOR
YOU ALLOWING US TO USE THIS
BEAUTIFUL FACILITY CALIPH OF
NATIONAL CITY IS CITY OF JUST
WONDERFUL AMENITIES. AND YOU
YOU ALL DO SUCH A GREAT JOB
THAT RUNNING THE CITY SO I'M
VERY PROUD. TO REPRESENT THE
CITY OF NATIONAL CITY AND THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO BE HERE
TODAY ALSO. I'D LIKE TO THANK
ALL OF YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
ESPECIALLY OUR PANELISTS THAT
ARE HERE TO SHARE SOME COMMENTS
ABOUT OUR OUR DEVELOPING OUR BY
NATIONAL IDENTITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR NOW AND BUT
CALIFORNIA SAN DIEGO TIJUANA.
AND REALLY WHAT IS THE WHAT
THEY CALL NOW THE LAW SENT THE-
LAW SENT THE THREE REGION
COMING FROM. LA TO TIJUANA. BUT
IT REALLY GOES BEYOND THE QUAN
I'VE DONE IT SINCE AND NOW THAT.
IT'S ABOUT. CALIFORNIA BUT THE
CALIFORNIA. AN AREA THAT IS
REALLY MYSTICAL WITH HISTORY
AND STUFF. IMPRESSIVE WHAT THIS
ENORMOUS ECONOMY THAT WITH THAT.
KEEPS US ALL OF OUR WORK
PROSPER IN AND WORKING VERY
HARD AND- THANKS IS ALSO PROUD
TO BE FROM. THE STATES. THIS
COMMITTEE THAT WE'RE HAVING
TODAY WAS CREATED TO ADDRESS
THE IMPORTANT ISSUES
SURROUNDING CALIFORNIA'S
COLLABORATION WITH MEXICO OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH MEXICO WHAT
WE CAN DO TO STRENGTHEN THAT
RELATIONSHIP TO BUILD ON OUR
COMBINED RESOURCES AND GROW
TOGETHER AND PROSPER TOGETHER
AS COMMUNITIES ALONG THE
BORDER. AS MYSELF REPRESENTING
THE ENTIRE CALIFORNIA BORDER
WITH WITH MEXICO. WE WILL I
KNOW WHEN WE ALL KNOW FIRST
HAND HOW IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH MEXICO IS OUR
LARGEST TRADING PARTNER AND
THIS RELATIONSHIP. IS CRITICAL
TO OUR STATE'S PROSPERITY AND
OUR WELL BEING WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA IS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY. AND MET OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH MEXICO
CONTRIBUTES A VERY LARGE PART
THAT PROSPERITY. THIS HEARING
WILL PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE- CURRENT
STATUS OF CROSS BORDER TOURISM.
AND WHAT ADDITIONAL POLICIES
AND MECHANISMS ARE NECESSARY TO
GROW CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC
RELATIONSHIP WITH MEXICO OR
ACROSS OUR SHARED BORDER I'M
HONORED TO HAVE MY COLLEAGUES
HERE WITH ME TODAY WE HAVE THEN
ALLEN IS ABOUT TEN MINUTES AWAY
PLEASE CEASE TO BE STUCK IN
TRAFFIC. FORTUNATELY BUT HE'S
ON HIS WAY AND WE ALSO HAVE
SENATOR STEVEN BRADFORD FROM
VIRGINIA AND IN LA COUNTY WE
ALSO HAVE OUR LOCAL CENTER
BRIAN JONES. FOR THE SANTEE
AREA AND WE ALSO HAVE SENATOR
HENRY STERN. FOR LOS ANGELES
AND VENTURA COUNTIES. ALSO HEAR
OF THESE ARE VERY IMPORTANT
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE THAT
MAKE UP THIS COMMITTEE. AND I
REALLY WANT TO THANK THEM FOR
MAKING THE TRIP OUT TO SAN
DIEGO TO BE PART OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO FORMALIZE A
DIALOGUE. AND EXCHANGE.
INFORMATION ON ISSUES THAT YEAH.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
MEXICO. I ALSO WANT TO GIVE A
VERY WARM WELCOME TO A VERY
CLOSE PERSONAL FRIEND A
WONDERFUL PERSON THAT JUST DOES
AN AMAZING JOB REPRESENTING THE
INTERESTS OF MEXICO OUR NEW
CONSOLE TO ST TO SANDY WITH
CARLOS GONZALEZ WITH THE
ADDRESS. JUST RECENTLY JOINED
OUR COMMUNITY NOT NEW TO
CALIFORNIA. BUT HE WILL NOW BE
THE REPRESENTATIVE MEXICAN SAN
DIEGO HE'S BEEN I HAVE TO SAY
ON INSTRUMENTAL PARTNER
FACILITATING. THE IMPORTANT BY
NATIONAL DISCUSSION SINCE I
ARRIVED IN SACRAMENTO I THINK
WE MIGHT ARRIVE AROUND THE SAME
TIME WHEN I ARRIVED HERE RIGHT.
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING TOGETHER
ALL THESE YEARS HE HE TOOK A
LITTLE SIDE TO THE AUSTIN HE
DID SUCH A GREAT JOB IN
CALIFORNIA THAT I THINK THEY'VE
SOFFIT TO PUNISH HIM. BUT WE'RE
REALLY SO HAPPY TO HAVE YOU
BACK I CAN'T SAY ENOUGH HOW
PLEASED AND WE ARE I AM AND I
KNOW THAT SENEGAL FIRST COME TO
REALIZE WHAT AN IMPORTANT.
RESOURCE YOU WILL BE TO THIS
COMMUNITY AS WELL SO WELCOME.
AND IF I'D LOVE TO INVITE YOU
TO SAY A FEW WORDS I MEAN YOUR
VISIT HERE IN YOUR PRESENCE
HERE IS VERY MOMENTOUS. AND IF
AND IF YOU'RE INTERESTED WOULD
YOU LIKE TO SHARE SOME COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE. ON
CALIFORNIA MEXICO CORPORATION
YOUR FRIENDS. THANK YOU SENATOR
BEING WAY SO. FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY PASS ROUTES TO OUR
SAYS SOME GUYS HAVE ALL THE
LOCK. IN MY PREVIOUS LIFE I WAS
BECAUSE WITH GENERAL OF MEXICO
IN SACRAMENTO. WHAT I MEANT
GERMAN WEST SO I HAVE MANY
FRIENDS PRESS AND TO THE. NOW I
GET THE CHANCE TO RECORD TO
RECORD NEXT WITH WITH THE
SENATOR. AND WITH ALL OF YOU
AND KEEP WORKING ON A STRONG
AGENDA TO PROMOTE MEXICO
CALIFORNIA'S COLLABORATION. I
BEGAN MY POST AS CONSUL GENERAL
OF MEXICO IN SAN DIEGO A MONTH
AGO. AND I CAN'T IMMEDIATELY
WITNESS THE STRENGTH OF THE
CROSS BORDER THERE RELATIONS IN
THESE REGIONS. THE CALIFORNIA
BACKPACK CALIFORNIA REGION IS A
MODEL OF SUCCESS OR BY NATIONAL
CORPORATION. THEY'RE CLOSE
INTERACTION IS AN EXAMPLE OF
THE ENORMOUS POTENTIAL OF CROSS
BORDER REGIONS FOR PRODUCTIVITY
INNOVATION INCLUSION ON OF
COURSE TOURISM. FOUR FIVE YEARS
AGO THE NEW YORK TIMES
PUBLISHED AN ARTICLE IN WHICH A
LOCAL SERVI FOUND OUT THAT MORE
THAN 60% OF SAN DIEGO RESIDENTS
HAVE NEVER CROSS THE BORDER. I
HOPE THIS CASTLE REALLY
CHANGED. I WILL DO MY SHARE
DEAR FRIENDS WORKING TOGETHER
WITH THE CHAIRMAN. AND WITH ALL
OF YOU TO RING SAN DIEGO ON
BEHALF. ALLY. MEXICO AND THE US
SHARE MORE THAN DOUBLE. WE ARE
STRONG PARTNERS AND FRIENDS THE
NAME. MY PRIORITY RIGHT NOW FOR
YOUR IDEAS YEAH SAN DIEGO.
AFTER A PERCENT MEXICO THEIR
CONSTRUCTIVE POLICY. SPECIAL.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND MAKE.
OR NOT FOR ME THERE WITH MY- BY
BEING THERE. IN THAT SENSE MY
PRIORITY WELL. RIGHT PARTNER.
CAN GO OFF. J. G.
HELLO AND
MAINTAIN MARK PROGRAMS IN
PARTNERSHIP. WELCOME. HI. A
LITTLE BIT OF BACK. OVERALL HOW.
RIGHT RIGHT. AS THIS CHART
INDICATES TOPPING HUNDRED FORTY
BILLION DOLLARS. THAT'S GREAT
NEWS CALIFORNIANS IT'S
GENERATING TWELVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN TAX REVENUE AND
EMPLOYING DIRECTLY OVER ONE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS IN MEXICO
IS A VERY IMPORTANT PART OF
THAT SUCCESS IT'S ACTUALLY ARE
UNDISPUTED NUMBER ONE
INTERNATIONAL MARKET AND COUPLE
THINGS I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
TODAY IS HOW WE PROMOTE
CALIFORNIA IN MEXICO WE TARGET
AS PART OF GOD AND OUR OVERALL
ALL DREAMS WELCOME MESSAGING AS
PART OF THAT CAMPAIGN WHERE
WERE ALSO PARTNERING WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT GOBIZ. ON GLOBAL
BRANDING AROUND ALL DREAMS
WELCOME FOR CALIFORNIA AS I
SAID MEXICO IS OUR NUMBER ONE
INTERNATIONAL MARKETS ARE
TWENTY NINETEEN VISITATION FOR
CASS'S IS PROJECTED TO REACH
SIX HUNDRED THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
THAT'S AIR ONLY THE ERROR I'D
PASSENGERS ARE REPRESENTING
ALMOST A BILLION DOLLARS IN
SPENDING BUT WHEN YOU COMBINE
THAT WITH ALSO THE CROSS BORDER
TRAFFIC OUR GROUND VISITORS
WERE LOOKING AT EIGHT MILLION
ANNUAL PERSON TRIPS AND ABOUT
THREE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN SPENDING. SO AS I
SAID IT'S OUR NUMBER ONE
INTERNATIONAL MARKET IT FALLS
WITHIN THE ARC TIER ONE MARKETS
MEANING WE INVEST HEAVILY IN
THAT MARKET WE'RE SPENDING
ABOUT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR IN THAT MARKET AND IT'S
ONE OF THE FEW MARKETS GLOBALLY
THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY SPENDING
DIRECTLY AGAINST THE CONSUMER
AS PART OF OUR CALIFORNIA DREAM
BIG GLOBAL BRAND INITIATIVE SO
MUCH SO THAT THAT WE HAVE MANY
ACTIVATIONS. TO ASSIST THE
FAMILY EXPERIENCE PILLAR IN
MEXICO BUT JUST TO GIVE YOU A
SNAPSHOT OF OUR BRANDING
EFFORTS IN MEXICO ARE ALSO YOU
CAMPAIGN IT'S CALLED SPOILED
LIKE WE'RE ALL SPOILED TO LIVE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND WE WANT
TO SHARE THAT WITH THE WORLD OF
COURSE ALL OF OUR SPANISH
SPEAKERS WILL UNDERSTAND AND
YOU'LL SEE SOME GREAT
CALIFORNIA CELEBRITIES LIKE
YEAH I GOT THE CONSTANT DAX
SHEPARD AND TYLER FLORENCE.
WELL THAT. CALIFORNIA SO MOST
OF THE SCHOOLS IN. A MUSICAL
BUT- WAS. NOT TO BE MUST NOT A
GIVEN CONTEXT THAT SOMEONE IS
THE COST. THANK YOU NOVEMBER
HERE IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
DISMISSED IT OUT THIS IS A MUST
WIN. THIS IS THE NAME OF THE
PAY THESE GOVERNMENTS BY SEVEN.
THIS IS RIGHT. WHAT IS THE MOST
WE CONSIDER. ALL THE SYSTEMS.
BEEN SINGLE SO THAT AS WE. ST
GLOBALLY BUT WE STARTED IN
MEXICO WAS ARE ALL DREAMS
WELCOME PAIN CAMPAIGN AS A
RESPONSE OF SOME OF THE
HEIGHTENED POLITICAL RHETORIC
THAT WAS COMING OUT OF
WASHINGTON AND THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS AND WE KNOW THAT WE ARE A
CULTURE OF INCLUSIVE THE
INCLUSIVITY AS WELL AS
DIVERSITY AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT FOR ALL THE WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE AND THE CONSUL
GENERAL SAID IT SO ELOQUENTLY
YOU KNOW IT'S MUCH BIGGER THAN
A TRADING RELATIONSHIP THESE
ARE FRIENDS FAMILY INCLUDING
MYSELF PERSONALLY. AND MANY OF
YOU THAT THAT SHARE THIS BORDER
IN THIS PLACE AND THIS COMMON
IDENTITY WERE VERY PASSION
ABOUT THAT IN CALIFORNIA HAS A
UNIQUE STORY TO TELL SO WE
LAUNCHED THE CAMPAIGN ALL
DREAMS WELL COME THAT WAS
LAUNCHED BY A DIPLOMATIC
MISSION OUR FIRST AND A TWENTY
FIVE YEAR HISTORY FOR WE
BROUGHT ON MANY OF THE GATEWAY
MAYORS DOWN WITH US A COUPLE
YEARS AGO INCLUDING THE MAYOR
OF SAN DIEGO TO TALK ABOUT. HOW
WE WERE YOU KNOW BUSINESS AS
USUAL THAT THE WE ARE FAMILY
AND THOSE CONNECTIONS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT AS WELL AS WORKING
WITH OUR MEXICAN COUNTERPARTS
AND CONSULATES AND THEY
MINISTRATION THERE IT WAS VERY
SUCCESSFUL IT HAS MULTIPLE
CHANNELS IN ACTIVATIONS AND IT
CONTINUES TO BE OUR. AND NOW
JUST LAST WEEK WE OPEN THE
CALIFORNIA WELCOME CENTER AT
THE CROSS BORDER EXPRESS AND
THEY'RE HAVING CURTAIN CREDIBLE
MOMENTUM AND GROWTH AND THAT
JUST IS OF PHYSICAL CONCIERGE
OF YOU KNOW PROVIDING THAT
ROLLING OUT OF THE RED CARPET
AND THE AND THE WILL COME OUT
FOR OUR FRIENDS AND FELLOW
TRAVELERS COMING FROM MEXICO ON
ME FRANKLY HE'LL TALK ABOUT ALL
POINTS IN THE WORLD INTO
CALIFORNIA IT'S VERY UNIQUE I
LIKE TO SAY AROUND THE WORLD
I'M I'M PART OF THE WORLD
TRAVEL AND TOURISM COUNCIL.
THAT WE BUILD BRIDGES NOT WALLS
AND THAT'S WHAT IT IS AND IT'S
YOU KNOW IT'S JUST WHAT A
WONDERFUL SUCCESS STORY AND
JUST LIVING THE DREAM OF WHAT
WE ALL SEE IS THIS BUY A
CULTURAL IDENTITY THAT THAT WE
ARE ALSO FORTUNATE TO SHARE SO
WITH THAT WE HAD ALSO CONTENT
ON AROUND MULTIPLE CHANNELS
WITH ALL DREAMS WELCOME AND SO
I'LL JUST CLOSE MY BRIEF
COMMENTS WITH THE VIDEO CONTENT
THAT THAT WE CHOSE TO. LAUNCH
AS PART OF THE FOLLOW UP TO THE
DIPLOMATIC MISSION THAT STILL
LIVES TODAY ALSO WHAT'S NEAT
ABOUT THIS IS THIS IS CURATED
CONTENT THESE ARE ACTUALLY REAL
PEOPLE JUST AND JOIN THE
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCE AND ALL
OF I'LL CLOSE WITH THAT. SO
IT'S C. ALDRIN'S WELCOME
. SO
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AFTER THE PANEL SAID
IT FROM ANYONE. THANK. WE
BEFORE WE CAN SET THE CONTINUE
TO OUR NEXT PANELIST I JUST
WANTED TO CONTINUE THANK GAIN.
OUR OUR VISITORS HERE AND THIS
EVENT IS INFORMATIONAL. BUT
IT'S ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO CONNECT SO I WANTED TO ALSO
THINK SOME VERY POOR PEOPLE
THAT WE HAVE HERE TODAY IN
ADDITION TO THE MAYOR OF
NATIONAL CITY AND IT COMES WITH
THE LOSS OF THESE AND COUNCIL
MEMBER. OF RON MORRISON WE ALSO
HAVE REPRESENTED HERE WHAT THE
OFFICE OF ONE OF OUR GUYS
MISTER MARTINEZ HERE TODAY
THANK YOU THE CARD FROM BEING
HERE WE ALSO HAVE FROM THE TIME
MRS CHAMBER OF COMMERCE LOOK ON
THERE MANY MANY THERON'S HERE.
VERY POINTED UP PROMOTING
TECHNICIAN ALSO WITH THE
NATIONAL CITY CHAMBER OF COM
COMMERCE JACQUELYN RIGHT NOW SO
IS ALSO HERE RAISE YOUR HAND
WHEN I CLICK THE SAVE SO PEOPLE
SAY HELLO THE SENEGAL REGIONAL.
CHAMBER I THOUGHT I SAW A LOT
OF A LOT HERE TODAY. AIR RAZOR
AND BE AFRAID. COURSE EVERYBODY
KNOWS HER HERE IN ALL THESE
INDIVIDUALS WERE STILL. NOW WE
ALSO HAVE JASON WILES WITH THE
SENATOR CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
AND WE HAVE A SUNNY SHOOTER
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER RUDY LAW
OFFICES HERE AS WELL. AND WE'LL
BE HEARING LATER ON WE'LL HAVE
SOME ANALYSTS HERE THAT WILL
INTRODUCE JUST A BIT BUT WE'LL
COME BACK TO OUR PANELIST AND-
WE HAVE WITH US TODAY WERE VERY
HONORED TO HAVE. BARBER NEWTON
THE PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
TRAVEL ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
IS THE VERY INFLUENTIAL UNIFIED
VOICE OF TRAVEL AND THE TOURISM
INDUSTRY CALIFORNIA WHICH IS A
THRIVING INDUSTRY WE JUST WANT
TO THANK HER FOR BEING HERE
TODAY TAKING THE TIME. TO BE
PART OF THIS PANEL THANK YOU
WELCOME THANK YOU SENATOR WAY
SO AND GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE.
AS YOU SAID CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION IS THE VOICE OF THE
TRAVEL AND TOURISM INDUSTRY FOR
THE STATE WE'RE ALSO KNOWN AS
CAL TRAVEL. AND WE PROTECT IN
ADVANCE THE INTERESTS AND
INVESTMENTS OF THE CALIFORNIA.
TRAVEL INDUSTRY THROUGH
ADVOCACY COLLABORATION IN
EDUCATION. SO OUR MEMBERS ARE
MADE UP OF THE CITY'S
DESTINATIONS HOTELS RESORTS
AIRPORTS AIRLINES RENTAL CARS
REALLY ANY ORGANIZATION FOR
WHOM TRAVEL AND TOURISM IS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THEIR
BUSINESS. IS A CATEGORY OF
MEMBERSHIP FOR US. WE APPLAUD
THE EFFORTS THAT A CENTER WHICH
WAS MAKING TO LEVERAGE TOURISM.
TO DEVELOP A POSITIVE BY
NATIONAL IDENTITY AND A VIBRANT
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN MEXICO AND CALIFORNIA.
AS CAROLINE SAID WE HAVE HAD
WE'VE BENEFITED FROM NINE GREAT
YEARS OF GROWTH IN THE TRAVEL
AND TOURISM INDUSTRY AND
CONTINUE TO SEE A VERY STRONG
ECONOMY. BUT I ALSO TALK TO
MEMBERS ABOUT WHAT ARE THE
CHALLENGES AND ISSUES THAT WE
THAT WE FACE IN THERE ARE A FEW
TROUBLING AREAS THAT WERE
FOCUSED ON IN ADDITION TO THE
NATIONAL MANMADE CHALLENGES AND
THE NATURAL CHALLENGES WE
PULLED OUR MEMBERS IN JULY ON
WHAT FACTORS THEY THOUGHT COULD
AFFECT THE TRAVEL AND TOURISM
BUSINESS THE MOST IN THE NEXT
TWELVE MONTHS. WE ASKED HIM TO
WRITE THEIR ISSUES FROM ONE TO
FIVE WITH FIVE BEING THE MOST
IMPORTANT. A NATIONAL TRAVEL
POLICIES WITH RATED FOUR POINT
THREE OUT OF FIVE. CALIFORNIA'S
IMAGE TO THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY FOUR POINT SIX TWO OUT
OF FIVE. AND CALIFORNIA'S IMAGE
TO THE REST OF THE WORLD FOUR
POINT SEVEN SIX OUT OF FIVE SO
MY MEMBERS ARE SAYING THAT
THEY'RE- A REALLY CHALLENGED BY
THE CLIMATE THAT WE'RE WORKING
IN THESE CONCERNS RANK HIGHER
THAN MANY OF OUR- HOT BUTTON
ISSUES LIKE HOMELESSNESS WHICH
WAS FOUR POINT. OH THREE OUT OF
FIVE OR SUSTAINABILITY WHICH IS
FOUR POINT ONE SIX OUT OF FIVE.
SO I THINK THESE RESULTS SPEAK
TO AWARENESS OF OUR STATE'S
TRAVEL AND TOURISM INDUSTRY
THAT WE REALLY NEED TO BE
PROACTIVE IN KERR JING VISITORS
TO COME TO OUR DESTINATIONS. WE
DO EMBRACE ALL LEGITIMATE
TRAVELERS I THINK YOU CAN SEE
FROM THE MESSAGING THAT'S
COMING OUT FROM VISIT
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO FROM OUR
INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS WE- SEE MANY
OF THEM CREATING COMMERCIALS
AND MESSAGING TO ENCOURAGE.
NEIGHBORS ESPECIALLY FROM THE
SOUTH TO VACATION IN CALIFORNIA
REALLY SEND THAT WELCOMING.
MESSAGE THAT WE ARE OPEN TO ALL
AND WE LOVE TO HAVE THAT
VISITATION. WE BELIEVE TRULY
THAT TOURISM IS THE BEST WAY TO
GET PEOPLE TO APPRECIATE
DIFFERENT POINTS OF VIEW IN
DIFFERENT CULTURES. SO WE
CERTAINLY AT AT CAL TRAVEL WE
UNDERSTAND THE DEEP
INTERDEPENDENCE OF MEXICO IN
CALIFORNIA FOR ECONOMIC GROWTH
FOR EMPLOYMENT FOR COMMERCE AND
FOR QUALITY OF LIFE ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE BORDER. AND WE
WANT TO SUPPORT POLICIES THAT
INSURE THAT CONTINUED SUCCESS.
AMONG OTHER STRATEGIES AT CAL
TRAVEL OR ADVOCACY. EFFORTS
SUPPORT INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT EASE OF TRAVEL
ACROSS THE BORDER INVESTMENT IN
OUR- REGIONAL AIRPORTS AND
EDUCATIONAL AND CULTURAL
EXCHANGES BETWEEN OUR TWO
COUNTRIES. WE WELCOME THIS
DIALOGUE IN THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
US TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF
SURVEY SO AND ALL THE LEADERS
HERE THANK YOU THANK YOU. I
FORGOT TO MENTION LISA COHEN HI
ARE YOU HIDING FROM ME
SOMEWHERE AND SEEING YOU THERE
YOU ARE. IT'S ME TWO NEAR HERE.
BUT CHULA VISTA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. WE WILL NOW GO TO OUR
NEXT PANELIST. LOOKING AT THAT
LOOK AT THE TWO NATION VACATION
AND THE REGIONAL IMPACTS OF
CROSS BORDER TERRORISM OUR NEXT
SPEAKER IS KERRY K. PITCH SHE'S
A CEO FOR THE SENEGAL TOURISM
AUTHORITY THE CENTER WITH.
TOURISM AUTHORITY SIX TO
IMPROVE TOURISM TO ECONOMICALLY
BET BENEFITS SENEGAL REGION.
TOURIST TOURISM IS THE SECOND
LARGEST SEGMENT OF THE SEND YOU
A CONDOM IN EMPLOYS
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
NINETY FOUR THOUSAND PEOPLE THE
SENEGAL TOURISM AUTHORITY IS A
PRIVATE NONPROFIT MUTUAL
BENEFIT CORPORATION COMPOSED OF
APPROXIMATELY A THOUSAND.
MEMBERS AND IT'S THOUGHT
THOUSAND MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS
BUSINESSES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND INDIVIDUALS SEEKING A
BETTER COMMUNITY THROUGH THE
VISITOR INDUSTRY THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY AND FOR ALL
THAT YOU DO FOR OUR REGION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
SENATOR AND THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING US HERE
TODAY WE'RE VERY EXCITED TO
TALK ABOUT OUR WORK THAT WE DO
TOGETHER. TO PROMOTE OUR BY
NATIONAL REGION SO A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE TOURISM AUTHORITY WE
ARE SIXTY FIVE YEARS OLD WE'RE
LOOKING PRETTY GOOD FOR SIXTY
FIVE OR NON PROFIT SO WE'RE A
FIVE OH ONE C. SIX AND OUR
MISSION IS TO ECONOMICALLY
BENEFIT THE SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY. SO WE ARE HERE TO
HELP DRIVE THE TOURISM ECONOMY
BUT ALSO TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE GOOD STEWARDS OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND CERTAINLY OUR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR FRIENDS
AND FAMILY AND NEIGHBORS TO THE
SOUTH IS A VERY IMPORTANT PART
OF THAT. WE HAVE AN OPERATIONAL
BUDGET THIS YEAR AT FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS SO WE'RE ABLE
TO DO A GLOBAL MARKETING
PROGRAMME FOR ACTUALLY
MARKETING SAN DIEGO IN EIGHT
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD. SO
WE HAVE A WONDERFUL COMMUNITY
THAT'S HERE THAT WORKS
TOGETHER. FROM A TOURISM
PERSPECTIVE FOR CONTEXT WE ARE
A TOP FIVE DESTINATION FOR
AMERICANS TO TRAVEL INTO OUR
COMMUNITY IN THE ELEVENTH MOST
VISITED FOR INTERNATIONAL
TRAVELERS OR TOP MEETING AND
CONVENTION DESTINATION THAT
STRONG FOUNDATIONAL BUSINESS
FOR ANY COMMUNITY. WE HAD
ALMOST THIRTY SIX MILLION
VISITORS THIS LAST YEAR INTO
SAN DIEGO AND WE'RE ONLY A
POPULATION OF THREE POINT THREE
MILLION WITHIN THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AREA SO THAT'S TEN
VISITORS FOR EVERYONE RESIDENTS.
WE SEE THIS RELATIONSHIP TWO
FOLD ONE IS MEXICO IS A MARKET
INTO SAN DIEGO IT'S A MARKET
INTO CALIFORNIA WE HAVE OVER
FOUR POINT SIX MILLION VISITORS
COME INTO SAN DIEGO ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS. MANY OF THOSE ARE
DAY VISITORS ARE COMING INTO DO
TOURISM PURPOSES LIKE SHOPPING
GO TO OUR TRACTION SKODA
RESTAURANTS WE HAVE ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
THAT STAY THE NIGHT FROM MEXICO
HERE IN SAN DIEGO. AND MOSTLY
IS TO VISIT FRIENDS AND FAMILY
WE ARE VERY CONNECTED COMMUNITY
THAT'S THE FABRIC OF WHO WE ARE
BUT THEN THIS BY NATIONAL
REGION SO PEOPLE COMING IN
PRIMARILY TO SEE THEIR FRIENDS
AND FAMILY BUT ALSO FOR LEISURE
PURPOSES FOR VACATION. AND OF
COURSE FOR BUSINESS PURPOSES AS
WELL. WE ARE VERY FORTUNATE
THAT WITH IN MEXICO WE HAVE
REPRESENTATION FOR SAN DIEGO SO
WE ARE WITH A GROUP CALLED PR
CENTRAL THEY ARE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND FOR US IN MEXICO CITY.
THEY'RE DOING TRADE DEVELOPMENT
THERE ALSO PROVIDING EDUCATION
FOR TRAVEL AGENTS AND TOUR
OPERATORS AND I SHOULD POINT
OUT OF THE GENTLEMAN WHO
ACTUALLY SUPERVISES THAT WORK
WHICH IS BILL HANNAH'S. WAY
FEEL MOST PEOPLE KNOW PHIL.
HE'S BEEN ON BOARD WITH US FOR
TWO YEARS NOW OVERSEEN THE WORK
THAT PEER CENTRAL'S DOING AND
OUR INTERNATIONAL MARKET
DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS. SO WE'RE
VERY FORTUNATE TO HAVE THAT
REPRESENTATION THAT EXTENDS OUR
STAFF SOUTH OF THE BORDER. WE
DO QUITE A BIT IN TERMS OF
BRINGING PEOPLE INTO OUR
COMMUNITY SO DOING PFAM TRIPS
WERE SOMEBODY ACTUALLY TRAVELS
INTO SAN DIEGO AND GETS THE
EXPERIENCE OF SAN DIEGO. AND WE
DO EVENTS WHERE WE GO INTO
MEXICO AND WE TAKE OUR
COMMUNITY DOWN TO MEET WITH OUR
TRAVEL PARTNER SOUTH OF THE
BORDER. SO WE'RE- ALWAYS DOING
EVENTS WERE DOING SALES
MISSIONS WE DO GROUPS WORRY
BRING MEDIA OVER INTO OUR
COMMUNITY OR WE BRING OTHER
AGENTS FROM AROUND THE WORLD IT
JUST SAN DIEGO. AND OFTEN TIMES
WERE DOING NOT ONLY SAN DIEGO
BUT ALSO BAJA CALIFORNIA AS
WELL. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE DONE SUCCESSFULLY AS WORK
TOGETHER WITH BEST DAY WHICH IS
AN OTA OUT OF THE MEXICO
MARKET. TALKING ABOUT THE KELLY
BAJA EXPERIENCE SO THIS IS A
TWO NATION VACATION WERE
PROMOTING A STAY IN SAN DIEGO
AND I STAY IN BAJA. WE WERE
ABLE TO DO THIS THROUGH
ACTIVATIONS WITH ADVERTISING
THAT WE DID IN MEXICO WE WERE
ALSO DOING A PRESENCE AT MALLS
AROUND MEXICO PRIMARILY MEXICO
CITY. SO PROMOTING THAT AS A
TRAVEL PACKAGE THAT YOU COULD
BUY THROUGH BEST DAY SO THAT'S
BEEN ONE THAT'S A VERY TANGIBLE
EXAMPLE OF HOW COMMUNITIES CAN
WORK TOGETHER. TO PUT TOGETHER
A TANGIBLE PRODUCT THAT CAN BE
PURCHASED. WE ALSO HAVE A VERY
STRONG PUBLIC RELATIONS PROGRAM
OF WORK AND WE OFTEN SAY THAT
JUST BRINGING PEOPLE INTO THE
COMMUNITY AND LETTING THEM HOW
THAT EXPERIENCE SO FOR A TRAVEL
WRITER TO COME IN. AND TO COME
TO SAN DIEGO AND TO ALSO GO
INTO THE BAJA COMMUNITY IS
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
RESONATING AS A STORY. EARLIER
THIS YEAR TRAVEL AND LEISURE
TALKED ABOUT THE SAN DIEGO
BAHAR REGION AS BEING THE BEST
OF BOTH WORLDS IT'S TRULY AN AN
AN IMPRESSIVE STORY TO BE TOLD
AND ONE THAT HAS RESONATED WITH
TRAVEL WRITERS FROM AROUND THE
WORLD. NOW WE ALSO WORK WITH
THE BAJA CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
AS TOURISM PARTNERS IN S.
DEVELOPMENT PARTNERS WE HAVE
SIGNED LETTERS OF AGREEMENT
BETWEEN OUR COMMUNITY AND ALSO
WITH TIJUANA AND IN SIN NADA.
WE'VE DONE SIGNING AGREEMENTS
TALKING ABOUT THE WORK THAT WE
DO COLLABORATIVE LATE WE
PROMOTE EACH OTHER ON EACH
OTHER'S WEBSITES WE PROMOTE
EACH OTHER WITHIN OUR VISITOR
GUIDE INFORMATION WE'VE DONE
PROGRAMS LIKE I MENTIONED
EARLIER WITH THE- BAJA
CALIFORNIA BEST OF EXPERIENCE
THROUGH THE O. T. A.'S. WE'RE
VERY ACTIVE PARTICIPANTS IN
THOSE GROUPS LIKE THIS WITH THE
SELECT COMMITTEE TALKING ABOUT
HOW WE WORK TOGETHER AND HOW WE
WORK TOGETHER BETTER SO WHETHER
IT BE THE SMART BORDER
COALITION. OR THE REGIONAL
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE MANY
DIFFERENT PARTNERS TO KEEP THAT
DIALOGUE IN THOSE
COMMUNICATIONS OPENED AND
STRONG. AND OF COURSE I
MENTIONED EARLIER C. B. ACTS IN
THE T. ONE AIRPORT VERY
IMPORTANT TO THE SAN DIEGO
REGION AND OUR REGIONAL ECONOMY.
SO I'M GOING TO END WITH A TV
SPOT THAT WE'VE BEEN RUNNING IN
THE MEXICO MARKET SO YOU COULD
SEE HOW WE'RE PROMOTING IN SAN
DIEGO. BUT AGAIN WE DO TALK
VERY MUCH ABOUT THIS BEING A BI
NATIONAL REGION AND IT'S A
STORY THAT WE TAKE OUT.
CONSTANTLY. VIEW
. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING US TODAY
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH. WE'LL
HEAR A NOW FROM CITY GONE ABOUT
THEM FOR GRAVES PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE SOUTH COUNTY. EDC
WHICH IS BANNED A PROMOTER
BRING IN INVESTMENTS TO THE
SOUTH BAY SO IF YOU GIVE US A
PERSPECTIVE ON. THE ECONOMIC
INVESTMENT PERSPECTIVE THANK
YOU GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
STANDARD AWAY SO IN THANK YOU
FOR HOSTING THIS AND TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR BEING IN
SOUTH BAY TODAY WE APPRECIATE
THIS. FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO
APPLAUD THE COMMITTEE FOR
INVESTIGATING THE OPPORTUNITY
TO JOINTLY MARKET THE STATES OF
CALIFORNIA AND BAJA CALIFORNIA.
FROM AN ECONOMIC PERSPECTIVE
TOURISM DOLLARS OR SOME OF THE
BEST DOLLARS YOU CAN BRING INTO
THE REGION FOR ONE SIMPLE FACT
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE BEEN ON
VACATION LATELY BUT USUALLY YOU
BRING UP FAT WALLET WITH YOU.
YOU SPEND A LOT OF MONEY IN
HOTELS AND RESTAURANTS AND
EXPERIENCES AND YOU BUY ALL
SORTS OF THINGS. AND THEN YOU
GO HOME. AND THE REASON WHY
THAT'S GOOD IS BECAUSE YOU
LEAVE YOUR TAX DOLLARS HERE AND
TYPICALLY DON'T USE THE
SERVICES THAT TAX DOLLARS
NORMALLY PROVIDE SO WE'RE
TAKING THE T. O. T. DOLLARS
FROM YOU AND REINVESTING THOSE
BACK INTO THE COMMUNITIES WHERE
YOU ARE. WE'RE ALSO TAKING THE
SALES TAX FROM THE TOURISTS AND
NOT USING THEM BUT TO SERVE
THOSE TERRORISTS TYPICALLY
RIGHT THEY GO HOME BUT
REINVESTING IN OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT OUR
COMMUNITIES AND CONTINUE. IN
DOLLARS THE OTHER THING THAT
TOURISM DOESN'T IF WE DO OUR
JOBS CORRECTLY AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IT MEANS SO WE'LL
GIVE OPPORTUNITIES TO SOME OF
OUR PARTICULARLY SMALLER
BUSINESSES. TO HAVE NEW A NEW
AND EXPANDED CUSTOMER BASE WITH
NEW TOURISTS COMING TO SPEND
SOME OF THAT MONEY IN THEIR
WALLETS I WANTED TO SHARE THAT
WITH YOU BECAUSE I DO THINK TO
REMIT TOURISM IS ONE OF THE
GREATEST ASSETS THAT WE HAVE IN
THE SAN DIEGO TO ONE AREA. AND
JUST TO SHOW YOU WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN SAN DIEGO
PARTICULARLY ANGELA VISTA I
JOIN WITH FAMILIES TO CALL ANY
INITIAL VISTA AND THE PORT OF
STANDING ON THE CITY OF CHULA
VISTA. IN CELEBRATING THE FACT
THAT WE JUST HAD A BRAND NEW
HOTEL AND CONVENTION CENTER
PROVED ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO IT
IS THROUGH THE REDEVELOPMENT
IT'LL BE A SIXTEEN HUNDRED ROOM
HOTEL MINIMUM. WITH OVER THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND SQUARE FEET A
CONVENTION CENTER AND THAT IS
ONE OF SEVERAL OPEN HOTEL PADS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE HAPPENING
ON THE CHULA VISTA BAY FRONT.
DREAM WITH ME FOR A SECOND OKAY
WE KEEP SAYING. WE'RE RUNNING
OUT OF ROOM AT THE CONVENTION
CENTER AT THE SAN DIEGO
CONVENTION CENTER WHAT ARE WE
GOING TO DO WE'RE GONNA EXPAND.
WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR THAT
EXPANSION HAPPENED WE DO
SUPPORT THAT EXPANSION THERE
SOMETHING ELSE WE CAN DO AND
THAT WOULD BE TO CREATE A WATER
TAXI SO WHEN YOU'RE AT COMIC
CON WILL SAY AT THE CONVENTION
CENTER INSTEAD OF TELLING YOU
GET IN YOUR CAR AND DRIVE TO
CHULA. TAKE IT AND GOING TO ONE
OF THE HOTELS ALONG THE
COASTLINE IN BAJA CALIFORNIA.
IT'S POSSIBLE AND WE CAN DO
THAT WE JUST HAVE TO DREAM BIG
AND THAT IS THE ESSENCE OF BY
NATIONAL TOURISM IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT SAYING HEY COME TO BOTH
OF US HERE ITS ABOUT THE
CONNECTIONS THAT WE HAVE TO
HAVE. OBVIOUSLY THE CROSS
BORDER EXPRESSED A CROSS BORDER
TERMINAL JORGE WAS ONE OF THE
FIRST GREAT THINGS THAT WE DID
IMPROVEMENTS TO OUR PORTS OF
ENTRY IS ESSENTIAL TO MAKING
THIS WORK. BUT WE CAN DO BETTER
AND THAT'S WHAT I WOULD
CHALLENGE THIS COMMITTEE
SENATORS TO DO IS TO NOT ONLY
MARKET OR BY NATIONAL AREAS BUT
INVEST IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE WE
NEED TO TRULY MAKE IT CONNECTED
AND TRULY MAKE IT A BI NATIONAL
EXPERIENCE. WE HAVE SOME UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITIES HERE IN THE
CALIFORNIA BAR HIGH AREA THAT
ARE ALREADY SERVED LIKE WE'VE
ALREADY MENTIONED A CROSS
BORDER EXPRESS. BUT THEN ALSO
SOME OF OUR CRUISE SHIPS AND
THEN OF COURSE CARS WALKING
ACROSS THE BORDER ALL THAT
STUFF WORKS. IF WE BAND
TOGETHER. WE CAN SHARE OUR
RESOURCES WE COULD MARKET THIS
AS ONE THE WHOLE REGION BOTH
THE STATE ABOUT HOT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TO THE
REST OF THE WORLD AND DO IT
MORE FOR DO SURELY RESPONSIBLE
YEAH I SHOULD SAY THAT MORE
COULD USUALLY RESPONSIBLE
MANNER THAN WE CURRENTLY DO
WITH BAJA MARKETING BAJA
CALIFORNIA MARKETING.
CALIFORNIAN SAYING YOU GET TWO
FOR ONE LET'S REALLY MAKE IT
TWO FOR ONE LET'S JUST TALK
JUST TALK ABOUT IT LET'S DO IT.
LET'S MAKE IT THIS GREAT THING
TO WHERE WE'RE PULLING OUR
RESOURCES AND HITTING THE REST
OF THE WORLD. I KIND OF KNOW
THAT IF YOU LIVE IN SAN DIEGO
YOU KIND OF KNOW ABOUT. THE BAR
HIGHER AND IF YOU LOOK BEHIND
YOU KIND. OF KNOW ABOUT
CALIFORNIA. BUT WHAT ABOUT THE
REST OF THE WORLD. WE HAVE SO
MUCH BIODIVERSITY HERE THAT
PEOPLE ENJOYING CAN SEE THAT WE
NEED TO TREAT DREAM JUST A
LITTLE BIT BIGGER. AND THEN
MORE CAR TO IMPLEMENT IT. I
WANT TO ALSO LEAVE YOU WITH AN
EXAMPLE OF SOMETHING IN SOUTH
COUNTY DC DID THAT I THINK
MIGHT MAKE. THE TOURISM HITS A
LITTLE BIT EASIER AND ACTUALLY
IT'S A CREDIT TO OUR KERRY AND
HER TEAM. SO CAN EIGHTY C.
REPRESENTS A CITY OF CHULA
VISTA NATIONAL CITY IMPERIAL
BEACH CORONADO. THE SOUTHERN
PART OF SAN DIEGO AND THE
COMMUNITIES OF ALL TIME I AM
ANITA. AND WE EMBARKED ON A
TOURISM EFFORT CALLED SAN DIEGO
SOUTH BAY WE HAD NOT WORKED
TOGETHER TO DO MARKET IN A
JOINT COHESIVE MANNER. AND THIS
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT ALLOWED US
TO. EXPOSE PEOPLE TO WHAT IS
TRADITIONALLY OVERLOOKED. AND
TOURISM OPPORTUNITIES IN THE
SOUTH BAY AND TO BEGIN WITH
THIS WE STARTED WITH THE
VOLUNTEER TASK FORCE. WE
CREATED A WEBSITE AND SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORM AND THAT
ALLOWED. MANY MANY DIFFERENT
PEOPLE TO IMPORT THEIR
INFORMATION ON TO THIS WEBSITE
AND ON THE SOCIAL MEDIA. BUT
THE MOST SUCCESSFUL THING WE
DID. WAS WE PARTNERED WITH THE
SAN DIEGO TOURISM. AUTHORITY WE
MET WITH JOE TURGEON SAID JOE.
WE'RE MISSING IT SOUTH COUNTY
COULD BE SO MUCH BETTER ON YOUR
WEBSITE WE CAN GIVE YOU THE
STUFF AND TO THEIR CREDIT. AND
I'M STILL GRATEFUL TO THIS DAY
THEY SAID GIVE US WHAT YOU'VE
GOT. GIVE US YOUR PICTURES GIVE
US YOUR YOUR ARTICLES GIVE US
EVERYTHING WE OKAY. MAYBE A
COUPLE HUNDRED KIDS TO EXPOSURE
TO OVER TWO MILLION VISITORS A
VISIT THEIR SITE ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS THAT'S THE KIND OF
EXPOSURE WE CAN HAVE AND I
THINK BY PARTNERING IN CROSS
PROMOTING EACH OTHER WE CAN DO
THIS IN A BETTER WAY I THINK BY
WORKING TOGETHER AND TRULY
GETTING THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN CAN ACTUALLY BRING THE
TYPE OF TOURISM THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE THIS WORK AND THEN LASTLY
IF WE DO IT IN A FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE MANNER BY POLINA
RESOURCES INSTEAD OF JUST
MENTION IT AT ALL BY THE WAY
THERE'S JUST AND THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY MAKE THIS A TRULY BY
NATIONAL EFFORT AND I THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. VERY NICE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE GLOBAL
ECONOMY BEGAN WHEN THE FIRST
ROAD WAS BUILT BETWEEN ONE
COMMUNITY IN ANOTHER IN THE
HISTORY OF MANKIND. AND ROADS
ARE WHAT CONNECT COMMUNITY IT'S
ROADS ARE PRIMARILY USED FOR
TRADE. AND EVERY TIME WE INVEST
IN BUILDING A CONNECTION IT'S
SOMETHING THAT HELPS TO
INCREASE OUR ECONOMY AND WE
HAVE FOUND THAT IN A STUDY THAT
WE DID HERE IN SENEGAL COUNTY
THAT REDUCING BORDER WAIT TIMES.
HELPS CAN CAN INCREASE
CALIFORNIA AND MEXICO THE
ECONOMY TO THE TUNE OF BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AND I'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY HARD TO DO THAT.
WE ESTABLISHED A FUND A PORTS
FUND. THAT WAS DESIGNED TO
REDUCE PORTER WAIT TIMES AND WE
DEPOSITED TO UNDER FIFTY
MILLION AS OUR STATE'S
CONTRIBUTION TO DO THIS. AND
WE'RE ACTIVELY PURSUING THOSE
LOCAL PROJECTS BORDER PROJECTS
PORCH PROJECTS THAT WILL HELP.
IN THE AREA OF TRADE BECAUSE
IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO GROWING
OUR ECONOMY OUR NEXT SPEAKER
CORE CORE OKAY WOULD TALK TO A.
IS THE CEO OF CROSS BORDER
EXPRESS A PROJECT THAT I HAD
THE PLEASURE OF WORKING ON WHEN
I WAS ON THE COUNCIL HERE IN
SAN DIEGO AND WE HAVE LOTS OF
PEOPLE HERE. IN THIS HEARING
TODAY THAT WERE INSTRUMENTAL
MAKING THIS HAPPEN INCLUDING.
MISTER GORE TALKED TO A IS THIS
IS A NINE THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY FOUR BRIDGE THAT
CONNECTS THE TIJUANA
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT WITH A
COMMUNITY OF ALL TIME MASON
SANDIEGO AND IT IS THE FIRST
BUILDING OF ITS KIND TO CONNECT
THE USA TO A FOREIGN AIRPORT
TERMINAL. AND IT IS BEEN AN
ENORMOUS SUCCESS IT WAS
ENVISIONED IT WAS IT JUST TOOK
AMAZING VISION TO SUGGEST THIS
PROJECT. BUT IT'S BEEN A BIGGER
SUCCESS THAN ANYBODY COULD HAVE
IMAGINED IN THAT THAT THEIR
PARKING CONTINUES TO EXPAND THE
FACILITY CONTINUES TO EXPAND
THE CONTINUE TO WELCOME. MORE
MEMBERS EVERY SINGLE DAY AND I
THOUGHT THAT'D BE VERY
IMPORTANT TO HAVE YOU HERE
TODAY THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
AND SHARING. YOUR EXPERIENCE
WITH THIS WONDERFUL ASSET THAT
WE HAVE HERE THAT FURTHERS OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO REDUCE FOR WAIT
TIMES AND ALSO. TO PROMOTE OUR
RECRUIT OUR REGION IS A BUNCH
BY NATIONAL REGION THANK YOU
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU SENATOR
WES ON THANK YOU ALL FOR HAVING
ALL SETS. AS YOU MENTIONED THIS
IS A BEAUTIFUL PROJECT ON I
SEND PRETTY NEW IN THE IN THE
REGION. EVERY TIME THAT I
INTERACT WITH PEOPLE I HEAR
THESE ARE COMMENTS OF EVERYONE
INVOLVED IN THIS PROJECT TO
MAKE IT HAPPEN SO WE'RE VERY
VERY HONORED TO BE PART OF THE
COMMUNITY. UNTIL CONTRIBUTED TO
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE TOURISM
INDUSTRY I'M ON THE REGION SO
NO QUESTION THAT THE RELATION
BETWEEN MEXICO AND U. S. IS KEY
I'M FOR US FOR CROSS BORDER
EXPRESS HE'S HE'S THE SOLE.
WILSON ALL CROSS BORDER EXPRESS
ASK PHOEBE X. I'M DONE LET ME
SURE THAT FOR MISCONCEPTION ON
A WE TENDED TO CHANGE THE POWER
OF THE HOME OF TRANSPORTATION
BETWEEN. THE US AND I'M
MEXICO'S SPECIALLY FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO MEXICO
OFFERING A FASTER AND MORE
CONVENIENT WAY TO CROSS THAT.
BC'S BORDER OF THE WORLD. AND
GIVEN THE FACT THAT. THE QUAD
AYRAULT POUR WHAT'S IN THERE
POOR. USE FOR MANY MANY YEARS
FOR ON NOT ONLY SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AND I
RECALL WHEN I START MY CAREER.
IN. NINETEEN NINETY TWO AND
WHILE I HAD A DOING CHECKING
FOR PASSENGERS. TO SEE PASSING
YEARS THAT THEY WERE BY IN
THERE TO GET SEEN LA
METROPOLITAN AREA BUT ALSO FROM
FOR THURSDAY'S LIKE OREGON
WASHINGTON ON. ORTON INVOLVED
AND NOW HE'S ON A SO TO TWENTY
REPORT HAS ALWAYS WIEN. I NEVER
FOR THAT HE'S USE FOR NOT ONLY
FOR MEXICAN AMERICANS BUT. FOR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RACY THAT'S.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE OF. THE
CLINIC TV THAT THE HORN AIRPORT
HAS. RELEASED A NUMBER TO A
REPORT IN TERMS OF DIRECT
CONNECTIONS FROM MEXICO WE'RE
GONNA END UP THE YEAR WITH.
THIRTY SIX DIRECT CD SERVED BY
T. ONE NOT ONE A REPORT SO
CLEARLY. IT MAKES SENSE TO
BUILD THESE THESE FACILITY
BECAUSE PEOPLE DO NOT WANT TO
WAIT. HOURS TO CROSS TO CROSS
THE BORDER SO. FOR MANY YEARS I
KNOW THAT THERE WAS RESEARCH ON
WHAT TO DO WE BUILT THAT BA BY
NATIONAL HERO FOR WHAT CAN WE
DO TO TAKE THE WHOLE POTENTIAL
OF PEAK ONE AIRPORT. ON THAT
WAS WERE CVS WAS MORE TO CREATE
ANY NORMATIVE SEE LOOK SOLUTION
ON. AN OFFERING THAT IS STATE
OF THE ART FACILITY. FOR WITH A
BREACH AT THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FEET BREACH TO CONNECTS.
THE QUAN AIRPORT TO GET IT
PASSENGERS WITH THAT'S HOW THEY
ARE AND CALIFORNIA AND
CURRENTLY I'M VERY PROUD TO SAY
THAT. 87% OF OUR USERS CROSSES
THE BORDER THERE ARE SCENES
DATE BECAUSE UP THE LUGGAGE
THERE ARE ALREADY IN SAN DIEGO.
WITHIN. FIFTEEN MINUTES SO
THAT'S THAT THAT'S FAST SO YEAH
THE. SO LET ME GIVE YOU SOME
SOME SOME FACTS SCENES CBS WAS
LAUNCHED IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN DECEMBER NINTH TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN. WE HAVE
ALREADY REACHED THAT SEVEN
MEDIAONE USERS MARK. AND WHAT I
MENTIONED ABOUT THE TEAK WON A
POTENTIAL THE CORNER A REPORT.
END UP IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
WITH FOUR POINT NINE TOTAL
USERS. IN THAT TEN YEARS TEN
YEARS BEFORE OF THESE ARE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN P. ONE AIRPORT
GREW 2% AVERAGE IN EACH YEAR
SINCE CV X. WAS LAUNCHED THE
QUANAH HAS GROW SEVENTEEN
PERCENT. YEAR OVER YEAR SELLING
THREE YEARS FIFTY A PERSON
GROWING IN TERMS OF PASSENGERS
AND THEIR CAPACITY SO REALLY
THESE HAS THE NUMBER TYPE DOT
DOT DOT DEVELOPMENT WE'RE VERY
PROUD OF THAT JUST THESE HERE
HAS BEEN FANTASTIC FOR US JUST
LAST JULY WE HAVE OUR- NUMBERS
ALREADY REACH ONE POINT SEVEN
FIVE MILLION USERS. AND WE
SPENT TWO AND THAT OF THE YEAR
OR THREE ME ON A USE OR SOUL
WE'RE WE'RE REALLY THRILL OF
THAT THEN WE I THINK THAT BODY
DAYS THAT THEY'RE NORMS
POTENTIAL OF TO REASON AND
TRIES BORDER TOURISM AND
SOMETHING THAT WE FEEL VERY
PROUD THESE TO BE PARTICIPATING
WITH. THE SEED CALIFORNIA SAN
DIEGO TOURISM ASSOCIATION AND
EVERYONE TO CREATE OF COURSE
THE MEXICAN TOURISM INDUSTRY AS
WELL TO CREATE THESE
PARTICIPATE IN THESE TWO
NATIONS VACATION WEEK IN THE
PAST THE MEXICAN USUAL HEIGHT
AND PASSENGERS WILL NOT DO THE
EXPERIENCE OF WAITING THREE
HOURS TO CROSS THE BORDER NOW.
THE TOURISM CAN COMMON GOAL
FROM C. V. X. HE I MEAN
EXPERIENCE EAST TO NATION BUT
CATION EXPERIENCE SO OVER THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS OF SENATOR
WAS SO MANSION ON WILL BE
BUILDING MUCH MORE THINGS MORE
SURPRISES TO COME. WE HAVE
FORTY THREE ACRES OF LAND ON
OUR EXPECTATION NEEDS TO BUILD
HOTELS ONE OR TWO HOTELS A
FIELD DECIDED CONFERENCE CENTER
RESTAURANT MERRY KERR CENTER ON
PARK OUR ADDITIONAL PARKING
LOTS OUR SERVICE CENTER GAS
STATION. SO WE WANNA REALLY
COULDN'T THREE B. EIGHT AND BE
.
A DETONATOR OF THE ECONOMY. IN
IN THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGION CURRENTLY THERE'S MORE
THAN FOUR HUNDRED JOBS CREATED
ON WE LOOK FORWARD TO CREATE
MUCH MORE IN THE COMING FIELD.
THE NATIONS IN MEXICO ARE
TAKING THE OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU
TO BE SEEN BUT ALSO. FROM THE
CALIFORNIA TOURISM INDUSTRY TO
PURSUE THESE PASSENGERS TO CALM
AND UCV X. AND DEVELOP THE
TOURISM INDUSTRY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS BACK
CALIFORNIA HAS SEEN AN ENORMOUS.
DEVELOPMENT OF. A VERY EXCITING
TOURISM INDUSTRY. IT'S SEENA A
DIVERSIFICATION OF ALL OF THE
PROGRAMS AND CULTURAL SERVICES
AND CULTURAL RESOURCES AND THE
FOOD INDUSTRY IS JUST BECOME. A
WONDERFUL PLACE TO VISIT IN THE
WORLD. AND I CAN'T THINK OF
ANYBODY SPEAKING VERY HONESTLY
THAT HAS HAD MORE TO DO THAT
WITH THAT. DONE OUR NEXT
SPEAKER US SECRETARY OF TOURISM
ABOUT CALIFORNIA WAS KIND OF
SCHOOL WITHOUT THROUGH HIS
VARIOUS ROLES AS A BUSINESSMAN
THROUGH THEIR THEIR CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE SCHOOL PART OF MAX AND
THROUGH CANNOT CALL AND AS HIS
CURRENT ROLE AS THE SECRETARY
OF TOURISM FOR THE STATE OF.
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE SEEN JUST
WONDERFUL THINGS HAPPEN IN BY
CALIFORNIA OUT THAT LYNN TO ALL
THE- GREAT PLACES PEOPLE HAVE
TO GO AND VISIT. THE FOOD SCENE
AND TAKE ONE IS NOW
INTERNATIONALLY RECOGNIZED THE
CULTURAL RESOURCES THAT ARE
STARTING TO APPEAR IN IN BAJA
ARE ARE SECOND TO NONE. AND WE
ARE JUST VERY HONORED TO HAVE
HIM HERE TODAY AND BE PART OF
THIS PANEL AND WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME. SECRETARIAL WAS CUT US
THIS CALL WILL BE A MANY THOUGH
SEEING THAT. I SUPPOSE THANK
GOODNESS KNOWS WHICH SOME OF MY
OWN BROTHERS. I WANT TO THANK
THE SENATORS FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND TO MAKE PUBLIC
THE NECESSITY TO DO SOMETHING
WITH TOURISM BETWEEN TWO
NATIONS. HELLO CARLOS. MANY OF
US ON THE AISLE THE ONE. I MEAN
JUST ALMOST. BETWEEN WHAT DOES
SENATOR WESSEL HAS SAID AND
HOTTER HERE I HAVE NOTHING LEFT.
I JUST WANT TO MENTION A COUPLE
THINGS ABOUT BAJA CALIFORNIA.
LAST YEAR WE HAD TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION PEOPLE WHO VISITED THE
STATE. OUT OF THOSE SIXTEEN
POINT FIVE ACCORDING TO C. B.
P. WERE PEOPLE FROM ACROSS THE
BORDER. WHO VISITED BY HOW BY
LAND. OUT OF THOSE AMAZING 82%
OF OUR PEOPLE FROM CALIFORNIA
SO FOR US IT'S A BIG IT'S A
HUGE HUGE MARKET. BUT ALSO
WE'VE GROWN. AS FAR AS THE
MEXICAN MARKET. A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO 80% OF OUR TOURISM
MARKET WAS FROM THIS SIDE OF
THE BORDER RIGHT NOW EVEN
THOUGH IT IT HAS INCREASED WE
HAVE A 55% FROM THIS SIDE OF
THE BORDER. AND 45% FROM THE
INTERIOR OF MEXICO. SO WHAT HAS
HAPPENED FOR EXAMPLE A FOUR
YEARS AGO WE HAD THREE POINT
NINE PEOPLE AT THE D. ONE
AIRPORT THIS YEAR WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE MORE THAN EIGHT MILLION
PEOPLE IN TIJUANA AIRPORT. BUT
NOT ONLY IN TIJUANA MEXICO ONLY
FOR THE FIRST TIME HAD OR
MILLION PASSENGERS BY OCTOBER
OF LAST YEAR WHICH IS 46%
INCREASE. IN PASSENGERS FOR
MEXICO SO THIS HAS BEEN THIS IS
A VERY GREAT WE'VE I'VE ALSO
HAD MILLION PASSENGERS ON THE
CRUISE LINES. SO THAT FOREIGN
SONATA WHICH IS NUMBER. ONE IN
THE PACIFIC IT'S ALSO
EXTRAORDINARY. BUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING WITH THIS HOW DID
THIS CAME ABOUT FIRST OF ALL WE
HAVE OF KNOWLEDGE WE HAVE TO
WORK ON A COUPLE OF THINGS ONE
OF THE THINGS IS THAT WE DID
NOT HAVE TO SELL DESTINATIONS.
WE HAD SOME EXPERIENCE. IT'S
NOT ONLY ABOUT THE FIVE STAR
HOTEL IT'S ABOUT YOUR FIVE
SENSES. SO WHICH CHANGED THE
WHOLE STRATEGY OF HOW WE DID
THINGS. AND AS A RESULT OF THAT
WE HAVE A STRATEGIC MARKETS
THAT HAVE BEEN VERY VERY GOOD
FOR US. BUT I'LL THOSE MARKETS
THERE'S A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
DO SOMETHING WITH CALIFORNIA.
WHICH THE TRUTH OF IT WE
HAVEN'T DONE ENOUGH. FOR
EXAMPLE. IT WAS MENTIONED HERE
THAT WE CAN DO THE TWO NATION
VACATION BUT WE CAN ALSO DO TO
NATION CONVENTION. WE CAN DO
HALF OF THE CONVENTION IN
MEXICO HALF OF THE CONVENTION
THIS SIDE OF THE BORDER WE HAVE
SEND OUT A THOUSAND METER OR WE
CAN HAVE TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE
AND THIS CONVENTION CENTER
WHICH IS ON GROUND LEVEL THAT
MEANS WE CAN DO. EXPOSITION ON
MACHINERY AND HAVE A CONVENTION
ON MACHINERY ON THIS SIDE OF
THE BORDER. WHICH HAS NOT BEEN
DONE BEFORE. BUT ALSO. WE CAN
DO SOMETHING EXTRAORDINARY AS
FAR AS TOURISM AS FAR AS THE
FILM INDUSTRY TOURISM. LAST
YEAR WE HAD. SEVENTY SEVEN. BIG
FILMS. FILMED IN BAJA
CALIFORNIA. WE CAN DO A LOT IF
WE GO HAND IN HAND WITH FILM
TOURISM. OR WITH CALIFORNIA
WHICH SOMETHING EXTRAORDINARY
WE HAVE NOT TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF.
ALSO WE HAVE FLIGHTS FROM CHINA
WHICH I THINK IT COULD BE
EXTRAORDINARY FOR SELLING
CALIFORNIA TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THIS AND DO A TWO NATION
VACATION WITH THE CHINESE
MARKET WHICH IS A HUGE MARKET
AS YOU ALL KNOW BUT ALSO YOU
HAVE TO FLIGHTS FOR EUROPE
WHICH THIS IN ABOUT NINETY FOUR
NO FROM EUROPE IT'S
COMPLICATED. WE CAN DO IT TO
NATION VACATION WITH WITH
EUROPE AND THIS DOES NOT MEAN
THAT PEOPLE ARE GOING TO SPEND
SIX DAYS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
IN CALIFORNIA ARE GOING TO
SPEND FOUR AND SPENT TWO IN
BASRA THIS MEANS IS THIS THESE
GUYS WILL SPEND TEN DAYS IN THE
REGION WHICH WILL BE HELPFUL
FOR BOTH OF US. AND THAT'S A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY THAT WE ALSO
HAVE. ALSO IN ADVENTURE BAJA
CALIFORNIA IS EXTRAORDINARY FOR
TOURISM IN ADVENTURE LIKE
CALIFORNIA BUT WE CAN GO HAND
IN HAND WHAT HAS THAT CAN'T BE
DONE ON THIS SIDE OF THE BORDER
CAN BE DONE ON THAT SIDE OF THE
BORDER FOR THE OPPORTUNITIES.
WHEN WE JOIN TOGETHER ON BOTH
SIDES CAN BE SOMETHING
EXTRAORDINARY. ALSO WITH THEM
IN DOING EXTRAORDINARY GOOD.
GREAT AS FAR AS MEDICAL TOURISM
FRANCO YOU'LL- WON'T LET ME
LIVE HERE. HERE LET ME
EXAGGERATE ABOUT ABOUT ALLY. WE
HAVE A LAST YEAR A TWO POINT
FOUR MILLION PEOPLE VISIT BAJA
CALIFORNIA FOR MEDICAL TOURISM.
IF WE CAN DO SOME OF THE
SERVICES FOR ON THAT SIDE OF
THE BORDER AND SOME OF THE
SERVICES ON THIS SIDE OF THE
BORDER I KNOW MEDICAL TOURISM
FROM CALIFORNIA SOMETHING
YOU'RE LOOKING INTO GREATLY I
THINK WE CAN DO SOMETHING IN
HAND IN HAND AND HAVE MORE
TOURISM MEDICAL TOURISM. ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER. ALSO
WE'VE MENTIONED BEFORE I SHOW
THE VIDEO I HAVE TWO MORE
COMMENTS FIRST. WE I MENTIONED
THE CAMPAIGN OURSELVES WERE
WE'RE NOT SELLING DESTINATIONS
BUT EXPERIENCE LET ME TELL YOU
SOMETHING WE WON THE VEST.
TOURISM VIDEO IN THE WORLD WE
HAD THIS RECOGNITION IN PORT
ALSO. A SPAIN WHICH OUT OF FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE COMPETE IT
COMPETED WE WERE NUMBER ONE
WHICH IS THE VIDEO GOING TO
SHOW YOU AND WE HAD OUR VIDEO
FOR FOODIES WHICH WE'VE DONE
EXTRAORDINARY CZARIST FORTIES
OUT OF TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
PEOPLE VISITED THE STATE 32%
THEY DID FOR THE FOOD FOR THE
WIND OR FOR THE CRAFT BEER.
ALSO THAT CAMPAIGN GOT AS
NUMBER TWO IN CONTEXT SO WE'VE
BEEN DOING A GOOD JOB AND I
HOPE WE CAN DO A BETTER JOB
COMBINED WITH CALIFORNIA. THIS
IS WAS SOMETHING I WASN'T GOING
TO MENTION SENATOR. BUT YOU
MENTIONED WHAT HAPPENED WITH
THAT C. B. X. LAST YEAR IN
WASHINGTON WE HAD A MEETING
WITH C. B. P. AND WE TOLD THEM
THAT. IS HOW THE TRAIN CROSSES
THE BORDER RIGHT NOW TO DELIVER
MERCHANDISE AND IT GOES BACK
AND FORTH. WE COULD DO
SOMETHING WITH A CHARLIE. WE
HAVE TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE USING
THAT TROLLEY WHICH COULD BE A
PRE CLEARANCE TROLLEY LIKE WE
DO IN CENTURY. YOU WOULD HAVE
20% LESS EMISSIONS YOU HAVE 20%
LESS TRAFFIC AND IT WOULD BE A
QUICK MOMENT OF YOU OF HAVING
20% MORE PERSONNEL. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS ALMOST THERE.
THERE WOULD BE NO. NOT LOTS OF
MONEY THAT WOULD BE NEEDED AND
FOR SECURITY PURPOSES ACCORDING
TO C. B. P. IN WASHINGTON SAID
IT WOULD BE MUCH EASIER TO
CHECK PEOPLE ON ONE TROLLEY
THAN TO CHECK NINE THOUSAND
VEHICLES SO THAT'S SOMETHING I
LEAVE ON THE TABLE THAT'S
SOMETHING WE CAN WORK WITH THIS
ADMINISTRATION OF THE FOLLOWING
ADMINISTRATION. IF YOU THINK WE
CAN DO SOMETHING WITH IT. SO
LET ME SHOW YOU I THINK WE HAVE
THE VIDEO I'VE BRAGGED ABOUT
ALL. OF THIS TIME. THIS IS AN
INVITATION. FOR THOSE WHO
PREFER THE ROAD LESS TRAVELED.
FOR THOSE WHO WANT MORE THAN
YOUR. THOSE LOOKING FOR THE
UNIQUE THE EXCITING. GENUINE.
AND THOSE LOOKING TO TRULY FEEL
TO DISCOVER NEW SITES.
PERSPECTIVES. TO TASTE ALL THAT
THE OCEAN AND SO I'LL HAVE TO
OFFER. BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT THE FIVE STAR HOTEL. IT'S
ABOUT THE FIVE. IT'S ABOUT OPEN
SPACE. IT'S ABOUT ENJOYING THE
JOURNEY AS MUCH AS THE
DESTINATION. IT'S ABOUT THE
MOMENTS THAT MAKE TIME STUFF.
AND REMIND US WHAT REALLY
MATTERS. IT'S ABOUT CONNECTING.
WITH NATURE. LIVE. AND IN MY
COLLECTION REALIZE. PLEASE WITH
THE LANDSCAPE EVERY STEP. WHEN
THE SUN RISES. PLEASE STAY WITH.
SO COME ALONG ALL THE DENTURES.
PEOPLE TIRED OF THE SAME OLD
THING. I WAS LOOKING TO EXPLORE
DISCOVER AND EXPERIENCE A
DIFFERENT. ONE ZERO TWO THREE
THREE. ISN'T JUST A PLACE IT'S
AN INVITATION. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND YOUR ATTENTION. THOSE
REALLY NICE IT'S NOT JUST PLACE
AN INVITATION BY FAMILIES COME
DOWN. READ ON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MS SECTOR THOSE VERY NICE.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS FOR THIS PANEL OR ANY.
THE COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS SENATORS. THE CENTER
JONES. YES THANK YOU BACK TO
KERRY'S PRESENTATION ON THAT
VISIT SPUR SENIOR TOURISM
AUTHORITY YOU MENTIONED THAT WE
ADVERTISE TO EIGHT COUNTRIES
I'M ASSUMING MEXICO'S OBVIOUSLY
ONE OF THOSE AND THEN I HAVE
WHAT ARE THE OTHERS AND. AND I
COME ROLLING LIMITING IT TO
EIGHT. MY NOT MORE. SO THANK
YOU YES SO WE ARE IN EIGHT
COUNTRIES MEXICO AND CANADA
ALSO CHINA AUSTRALIA JAPAN
UNITED KINGDOM AND GERMANY WE
FOCUSED IN ON MARKETS WHERE
THERE IS VOLUME OF TRAVELERS
INTO SAN DIEGO AND INTO
CALIFORNIA OR WERE WE HAVE
DIRECT ACCESS WHERE WE NEED TO
SUPPORT THOSE AIRLINES THOSE
AIR CARRIERS WE WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE SAN DIEGO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT IF WE HAD
FOR MANY WE GO OUT TO MORE
COUNTRIES. YEAH. WELL AFTER
WATCHING THAT THAT VIDEO I'M
VERY HUNGRY AND I WANT TO GO
SURFING. SO THANK YOU SECRETARY
ESCOVEDO. FOR THAT ENTICING
INVITATION I REPRESENT AN AREA
A LITTLE FURTHER NORTH OF US SO
ALL DUE RESPECT TO SAN DIEGO IN
THE SOUTH COUNTY I REPRESENT
THE PART OF LOS ANGELES AND
VENTURA COUNTY. IN MALIBU IN
THE SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS AND
I JUST I JUST WANT TO THANK
SENATOR WAY SO IN THIS
INCREDIBLE COMMITTEE. BOTH OF
OUR COUNTRIES HAVE SO MUCH TO
OFFER WHEN I THINK OF MY
CHILDHOOD GOING DOWN ACROSS THE
BORDER TO GO SURF WITH. MY
BUDDIES IN SALIDA BUT NOW IN IN
MY LATER YEARS GOING TO BUY A
INVITED WANNA LUPE AND LOOKING
AT WINE COUNTRY THINK OF PLACES
LIKE MALIBU AND NAPA AND ALL
THE- THE AMAZING OPPORTUNITIES
CALIFORNIA HAS TO OFFER AND-
THE MIRROR IS RIGHT THERE. DOWN
TO THE SOUTH OF US SO I SEE THE
FUTURE IS INCREDIBLY BRIGHT FOR
A PARTNERSHIP THAT EMBRACES
THIS TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MAKE IT
POSSIBLE. THAT SEES THE TAX
BENEFITS OF THAT KIND OF
TOURISM GROWTH AND OPENS OUR
ARMS TO WITH THOSE THANK. YOU
CHAIRMAN WAY SO FOR A GIVEN
THIS OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU AND
ANYONE ELSE CENTER I'LL. I ALSO
WANT TO THINK GUNS ANYWAY SO
FOR PROPONENTS TOGETHER AND ALL
THE GREAT SPEAKERS IT'S REALLY
BEEN FANTASTIC I I'VE BUT NO
SOONER WAS SO THANKS A LOT OF
PEOPLE I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO THINK A GROUP IS VERY
SPECIAL TO ME THAT'S THE AUDIO
VISUAL PEOPLE. AND THAT'S
BECAUSE I WAS ABLE TO DRIVE
DOWN FROM LOS ANGELES AND WATCH
AND NOT NOT MISS A BEAT ON THE
ON THE HEARING SO I APPRECIATE
YOU THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE NOW DOING ALL UP AND DOWN
THE STATE EVERY SINGLE HEARING
NO MATTER WHERE IT IS. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS LIVE
STREAM FOR FOLKS TO TUNE IN SO
THEY CAN KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH OUR STATE SENATE
AND INCLUDING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AS THEY'RE ON THEIR
WAY SO I APPRECIATE THAT A
GREAT DEAL I YOU KNOW I'M
EXCITED THAT WE'RE WE'RE
ACTUALLY AND THEY'RE GONNA GET
A CHANCE TO EXPERIENCE SOME OF
THINGS THAT WERE. ON THE VIDEOS
BUT I WANT TO GET. A BETTER
SENSE FROM EVERYBODY ABOUT. YOU
KNOW HOW HOW THINGS WORK IN
TERMS OF GOVERNMENT FUNDING FOR
TOURISM PROMOTION AND IN BOTH
IN THE IN BOTH OF OUR
RESPECTIVE STATES AND HOW HOW
THAT YOU THE INTERPLAY BETWEEN
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC SECTOR FUNDS
FOR THIS KIND OF WORK AND- AND
YOU KNOW LET THE VIDEOS LOVE
THAT LOVE THE AS I MEAN YOU
WANT TO. TRAVEL BOTH STATES
MORE SUBLET ASK THE PANEL ABOUT
ABOUT HOW THAT THE FUNDING
MECHANISMS WORK. SURE SO FOR
CALIFORNIA CITIES MOST OF US
ARE FUNDED THROUGH AN
ASSESSMENT THROUGH TOURISM
MARKETING DISTRICT. THAT
ASSESSMENT IS CHARGED ON
VISITORS INTO HOTEL ROOMS THAT
GOES TO A BOARD THAT THEN
ALLOCATES THOSE FUNDS. SO FOR
SAN DIEGO IT'S THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO TOURISM MARKETING
DISTRICT IS WHAT PROVIDES OUR
FUNDS. WE RECEIVE NO FUNDING
FROM THE GOVERNMENT DIRECTLY.
BUT THAT THIS IS A BAD DISTRICT
IS THAT ANTI EARLY VOLUNTARY OR
IT'S ESTABLISHED BY THE
GOVERNMENT ALL OF THOSE IT'S
LEGISLATED BY THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO. AND IT IS A SELF
ASSESSMENT AND IT IS HAS
CRITERIA IN TERMS OF IT BEING A
BENEFIT DISTRICT BUT THE
HOTEL'S VOTING TO SS THEMSELVES
AND THEIR GAS. NOW IF YOU ARE
ON SO. NOW IF A HOTEL IS WITHIN
THE DISTRICT BUT DID NOT VOTE
TO MAKE HE SAYS BUT THEY STILL
HAVE TO PAY. IF YOU MEET THE
CRITERIA OF THE ASSESSMENT
DISTRICT IN EVERY DISTRICT IS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT FOR THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO IT'S HOTELS
WITH SEVENTY ROOMS FOR MORE HI
THAT ARE ASSESSED IN IF YOU
HAVE A MAJORITY OF THOSE
ASSESSED ROOMS. AND PROPERTIES
TO VOTE YES TO DO THAT THEN YES
IT IS AN ASSASSIN SPECIFICALLY
FOCUS ON HOTELS CORRECT ONLY
HOTELS. OKAY AND SEND YOU A WE
ALSO THERE'S THAT MECHANISM IN
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO AND IN
ALL CITIES INCLUDING THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO IN ADDITION ALL.
AROUND THE FUNDING COMES FROM
THE T. O. T. FUNDING THAT COMES
FROM. THE IT'S CALLED THE
TRANSIENT OCCUPANCY TAX THE
CITY'S COLLECT TRANSIT NOT TO
OCCUPANCY TAXES AND THEN CITY
COUNCILS AND MAYORS WILL CHOOSE
TO WEAR THOSE DOLLARS SHOULD.
PROBABLY SENTENCE OF THOSE I
KNOW AT LEAST IN THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO IN MOST CITIES IN
THIS COUNTY. GO TOWARD
PROMOTING THE CITY AND TO
RESOLVE AND. EVENTS THAT
TRACTORS SOME CREDIT CAN FIND.
A THEY CAN FUND. THE MOBILE
MARKET THEY COULD FIND.
CONCERTS THEY CAN FIND.
DIFFERENT LOCAL AFFAIRS AND.
EVENTS AND SO ALL OF YOUR
FUNDING COMES FROM AN
ASSESSMENT DISTRICT CORRECT NOT
OKAY SO IT IS THREE THAT
PRIVATE MECHANISM THAT OUR
FUNDING COMES THROUGH VERY
INTERESTING PUBLIC PRIVATE
THING I GUESS TO GET TO THE
EXTENT THAT IT'S AUTHORIZED BY
LEGISLATION IT IS I'LL DO IT
ALL THE OTHER SO THAT AND THAT
VISIT. CALIFORNIA AD THAT WE
SAW THAT THAT DOES THAT COME
OUT OF. WELL WHO FINDS THE
CALIFORNIA. SERVICE A
CALIFORNIA IS ALSO AN
ASSESSMENT DISTRICT. FOR THE
DAY SO FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IT IS A VARIETY
OF BUSINESSES THAT ARE IN THAT
ASSESSMENT DISTRICT. SO IT IS
BASED ON WHETHER YOUR BUSINESS
IS BENEFITING FROM TOURISM. WE
DO THERE WHAT'S THE NATURE OF
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE FUNDS.
BASICALLY IT'S A 3% TO FORTY
TAX WHICH HOTELS WHICH OUT OF
THAT WE GIVE 29% TO THE CITIES
AND THE STATE DOESN'T BELLA
CAMPAIGN AND EACH CITY DOES
THEIR OWN. THEIR OWN CAMPAIGN
COM. OKAY APPRECIATE THAT THANK
YOU VERY INTERESTING THANK YOU
GUYS. ONLY THREE. WHAT 3% TO GO
THERE. 3% PROCESS 3% TOTAL.
THANK YOU I'M SECRETARY I HAD A
QUESTION AS IT RELATES TO
MEDICAL TOURISM AND IS IT A
PARTICULAR SPECIAL SPECIALTY
THAT. CALIFORNIA'S GO DOWN. TO
VISIT A PHYSICIAN FOR OR IS IT
JUST OVERALL GENERAL HEALTH
CARE AND. THESE ARE IN
INSURANCE POLICIES PRETTY MUCH
RECEIVED. ALL BUT I JUST USE
EXTRA TO RESUME SO I JUST YOURS
AS WELL. BASICALLY IT'S A-
DEPENDS ON THE CITY LIKE I LOST
A LOT OF DENTISTRY. FRANKLY FOR
EXAMPLE HAS AN HMO FOR PEOPLE
FROM CALIFORNIA THAT SIDE OF
THE BORDER AND JUST PEOPLE WHO
DO FREE AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
PLASTIC SURGERY ALSO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU WHAT WHAT
WHAT YEAH. WE NEED TO GET TO
THE AIRPORT. SENATOR WAS VERY
POLITE HE PAY MAY I WANT TO
ALSO PROMOTION IS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR DEVELOP TO RESUME
BUT ALSO THE WHOLE PROCESS AND
I WENT OUT TO POINTED OUT
SOMETHING THAT WOULD REALLY.
HELP TO DEVELOP MORE TOURISM
CROSS BORDER TOURISM. I'M
THAT'S A DAY AT THE FEDERAL I
NINETY FOUR TAX WHEN YOU CROAK
WHEN YOU ARRIVE BY BY AIR YOU
ALREADY HAVE THAT. TAX BASED ON
YOUR YOU CAN WHEN YOU CROSS BY
LAND. EVEN DOUG TRAILER BORDERS
OR CV. IF YOU HAVE TO GO TO A
SECONDARY PROCESS ON
IMMIGRATION. AND THAT'S BECAUSE
IF YOU'RE DRIVING MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE MILES. ENGLAND YOU
NEED TO PAY THAT THAT THAT'S
THAT IT'S A BIT HARDER FOR THE
CUSTOMERS AN ADDITIONAL
PROCESS. AND THERE IS NO
COMMONALITY UP ON THE BOARD
THIS RECENT TAX US. IF YOU ARE
HUNDRED MILES IN SEE LAND YOU
DON'T PAY THAT THAT HAS SO I
THINK. THERE WILL BE A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY. TO KEEP
DEVELOPMENT IN THE TOURISM THE
TRANSPORTER TOURISM. IF WE CAN
EXTEND THAT LINE OF WORK DOES
THAT TRAVELERS NEED TO PAY THAT
THAT THAT SO I CAN BRIEF YOU
MORE. ABOUT THAT BUT THAT IS A
HUGE OPPORTUNITY WILL WELCOME
MORE PASSING YEARS MAKE THE
PROCESS MORE EFFICIENT. I'M
JUST GLAD TO PRIMARY PROCESS
WITH IMMIGRATION AND THAT IS
TAX. LAW ON THE SIDE OF THE
BORDER HE FOUND THE US TAX
YEAH. CARRETERA FEDERAL TAX ON
ON OUR SIDE OF THE BLOCK HERE
RIGHT. IT'S NOT THE SAME IN
EACH STATE TEXAS I MENTIONED
THIS ALREADY HUNDRED MILES
WHERE YOU CAN DRIVE FREELY
WITHOUT PAIN THAT THAT'S
HEARING CALIFORNIA'S ONLY
TWENTY FIVE MILES SO IF YOU GO
FOR YOU. IN ORDER OF SAN DIEGO
YOU NEED TO. CALL AND DO THE
SECONDARY PROCESS WITH C. B. P.
AND MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING. WE
CAN WORK WITH THEIR LOCAL
CONGRESSMAN FROM VARIOUS. HE'S
BEEN A REALLY GOOD ADVOCATE FOR
HELPING YOU REDUCE PORTER WAIT
TIMES HE'S ACTUALLY BEEN
PRETTY. RIGHT ON HUGE IN
HELPING US WITH ALL OF THAT
STUFF WITH. HE LET ME SOMEWHERE
IN THE SYSTEM AND ALL WE HAVE
TWO PEOPLE ON TONYA ON. EDDIE
MAYER HERE RIGHT BUT IN MY ****
FROM THIS OFFICE SO. NO THIS
GENTLEMAN NOTES. THANK YOU
WHICH WE SHOULD LOOK AT THAT
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU AND WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
WITH OUR PANELISTS. WE HAVE A
WITH US THE VERY DISTINGUISHED
PROFESSOR OF ON THE WEST COAST
FOR ALMOST. HE'S THE
COORDINATOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEXICO PROJECT THAT HE'S BACK
AGAIN HE'S TESTIFIED AT OTHER.
COMPANIES HERE IS THAT HE'S HAD
HIS TESTIMONY IS ALWAYS VERY
INSIGHTFUL SO WE WELCOME HIM
BACK OFTEN. WE ALSO HAVE THEIR
NEEDS. REEVE THE ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR OF THE UC MEXICO
INITIATIVE THAT I PRONOUNCE IT
CORRECTLY. GREAT THANK YOU AND
THE NEXT PANEL AFTER THIS ONE
WOULD BE ON THE HEALTH CARE. UP
PART OF TOURISM AND THANK YOU.
WHAT IS. THERE A WAY SO AND
CERTAINLY IT'S A GREAT HONOR
FOR ME TO PARTICIPATE THANK YOU
FOR THE INVITATION. AND WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO DO IS TO BRING IN
TO CONTEXT ROLE OF EDUCATION IN
THIS. UP BY NATIONAL IDENTITY
THAT WE'RE SEARCHING FOR. AN
AND SOMETHING THAT MAY NOT BE
S. EXCITING OR AS ADVANCED THE
CDC IN THIS CASE THE AT THE
HUGE IMPACT THAT TOURISM IS
HAVING. ALONG THE BORDER SO IT
IS A BIT OF A CHALLENGE I
WANTED TO. ALSO REMIND YOU THAT
WE'RE ALSO CONNECTED BY THE
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEMS ACROSS THE
BORDER BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND
MEXICO. THROUGHOUT BUT THERE IS
VERY LITTLE. VERY VERY LITTLE
EXCHANGE OF FACULTY AND
STUDENTS SO LET ME GIVE YOU
JUST A BACKGROUND AND
EXPERIENCE THAT I HAVE. BECAUSE
AND AGAIN LET ME JUST RE
INTRODUCE MYSELF I AM PURPOSE
ARE MONDO BASKET ALMOST SELF
FROM WHAT CAL STATE LONG BEACH.
AND SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE I
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED WITH
CALIFORNIA MEXICO EDUCATIONAL
EXCHANGE. AND I HAVE THE TEAM
IN MANY LOCATIONS STUDENTS A
PACK OF P. TO STUDY IN MEXICO
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX. I
ALSO WORK IN THE SEA IS YOUR
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN THE
OFFICE OF INTERNATIONAL
PROGRAMS FOR ALMOST THREE YEARS
BACK IN THE MID NINETIES. AND
IN SIX IN NINETEEN SIXTY NINE I
WAS IS CO FOUNDER OF THE CAL
STATE LONG BEACH KIND OR LATINO
STUDIES DEPARTMENT I KNOW THAT
THEY NEED TO BE ARRESTED SECOND
FIFTY YEARS AGO. BUT I WAS ONE
OF THE MAY CHANCE TO THE METER
SO WE WERE THE STUDENTS THAT
OPENED THE DOORS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA. PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES I
MEAN THAT ROLE I'M I'M I'M A
VERY PROUD ACTIVITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN NOW FOR MORE THAN THIRTY
YEARS FOLLOWING. OR NOT
PROMOTING THIS EDUCATIONAL
EXCHANGE BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND
MEXICO. I HAVE ALSO BEEN
FOLLOWING AND I BELIEVE THAT
TODAY'S HEARING IT IDEALLY
COINS SITES WEIRD GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM'S INITIATIVES. TO
RESTORE BILATERAL COOPERATION
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND MEXICO.
AND THIS HAS TO DO ALSO IN
PARTICULAR WITH HIGHER
EDUCATION I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO THE PRESENTATION BY MY
COLLEAGUE GOING WHAT THE UC
SYSTEM. HASH AND OF COURSE THE
GOVERNOR IS PURSUING RE OPENING
THE OFFICE IN MEXICO CITY. THAT
WAS SHUT DOWN BACK IN THE EARLY
TWO. I WAS IN THIS UNDER THE
TEN YEAR OF GOVERNOR GRAY
DAVIS. BUT THIS INITIATIVE BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOME IS TO PROMOTE
NOT ONLY HIGHER EDUCATION BUT
ALSO TRADE AND COMMERCE.
INNOVATION AND RESEARCH AND
CREATES A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO LEAD THE WAY. US
POLICY SOME PROGRAMS OF THE
SAFER ARE SHAPED OVER THE NEXT
FEW YEARS THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE HAD MEXICO CITY WAS OUR
LARGEST. OFFICE IN THE WORLD.
AND OF COURSE GIVEN THE
DOWNTURN AT THAT POINT HE WAS
HE WAS THE GOVERNMENT WAS
FORCED TO CLOSE IT. BUT IN MY
OPINION WHAT IS MOST IMPORTANT
TO DATE IS THE OPPORTUNITY THE
LIVE CIRCUIT AND THE LEADERSHIP
THAT THIS COMMITTEE. CAN
PROVIDE TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE IN. LONG TERM SET
OF HIGHER EDUCATION POLICIES.
THAT REFLECTS THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEXICO
RELATIONSHIP IN THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY. FOR A REGION
THAT IS ALREADY ONE OF THE MOST
PRODUCTIVE IN THE WORLD.
HOWEVER IN THE CASE OF THE
KELSEY SYSTEM ONE LIKE THE UC
MEXICO INITIATIVE AND THIS IS
FOR OUR CALL THE WHEEL. GIVING
BACK RUNNING TOURISTS WHO WHAT
THE UC SYSTEM HESS WITH MEXICO
THE YOU IN THE C. ISSUE THE
COMPANY'S THE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM
LACKS A SIMILAR INITIATIVE. AND
AFTER THE THREE YEAR BAN ON
TRAVEL TO MEXICO BY FORMER
CHANCELLOR SEES YOU CHANCELLOR
CHARLIE REED THE SYSTEM HAS
BARELY RETURN TO ABOUT THIRTY
PERCENT. OF THE FORMER IN ROME
IN IN THIS YEAR'S YOU MEXICO
STUDY ABROAD PROGRAM. I HAVE
SHARED THIS PRESENTATION WITH
THE MEMBERS OF THE OF THE
COMMITTEE THE SENATORS THAT ARE
WITH US AND YOU MAY SEE THAT
CHART. IT IS VERY VERY LOW. AND
THE IDEA OF COMMON KEEN ON THIS
IS TO PROMOTE WHY WE NEED TO
EXPAND WHY WE NEED TO IMPROVE.
IN PARTICULAR WITHIN THE CSU
SYSTEM. BUT ALSO ACROSS
CALIFORNIA'S. HIGHER EDUCATION
ALL THREE SYSTEMS THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE A HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THEY HAVE STUDY
ABROAD. AND IN THIS CASE THIS
YOU YOUR SYSTEM HAS BARELY
RETURN TO ABOUT 30% OF THE
FORMER IN ROME AND BACK IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES WHERE I
WORKED AT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE. WHICH AT THAT TIME WAS
UP ABOUT. SIXTY FIVE TO SEVENTY
STUDENTS SYSTEM WIDE. OUR
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT APPROXIMATELY
THREE STUDENTS FOR CAMPUS WELL
LET ME TELL YOU AND THIS IS
SOME RESEARCH THAT I DID THIS
IS UPDATED INFORMATION JUST GOT
WITHIN THE LAST FEW DAYS. WE
HAVE NOW IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS
IN ROLE ONLY. EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN
THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE AND THIS
YEAR ELEVEN. IN THE C. ISSUE
MEXICO STARTED A PROGRAM WHICH
IS HOUSED AT THE IN THE THEY
TAKE THE MONTERREY CAMPUS AND
GET IT THOUGH. USED TO BE IN
MEXICO CITY AT THE BETTER MANY
KINDA. BUT IT IS VERY
CONSISTENT AT THIS CONCERNING
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A MUCH
GREATER AMOUNT OF STUDENTS FROM
CALIFORNIA'S KELSEY SYSTEM IN
LET ME GO ON TO REFLECT. WHY
THIS IS OF GREAT CONCERN THIS
YEAR'S YOU HAS GROWN TO MORE
THAN FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
STUDENTS TO BECOME THE LARGE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IN THE UNITED
STATES WITH MORE THAN A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND MEXICAN CHICANO
LATINO. ENROLLMENT ONE THIRD
AND GROWING CLOSE TO BECOME THE
MAJORITY WITHIN THIS DECADE IN
THE C. ISSUE SYSTEM AND TOPPING
MORE THAN 30% CURRENTLY. GIVEN
THE GROWING INTERDEPENDENCE
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AS THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY THE WORLD AND
MEXICO AS THE THIRTEEN LARGE
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD THIS ALSO
REPRESENTS THE LET THE NURSERY
SIGNIFICANT HUMAN RESOURCE.
THAT COULD BE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO THE ECONOMIC
FUTURE OF THE CALIFORNIA MEXICO
REGION AND THAT ALL CONNECTS
WITH HAS BEEN PRESENTED THIS IS
DUE TO UNDERSCORE WHY WE NEED
TO DO MORE. AND ONE DONE A
REALLY THERE HAS BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT DECREASE SCENE IN
THE CALIFORNIA MEXICO
EDUCATIONAL EXCHANGE DUE TO THE
C. ISSUES BAN BUT ALSO DUE TO
THE DOWNTURN OF THE ECONOMY AT
THAT POINT WHEN THE BAN WENT
INTO EFFECT. AND THE FEAR THAT
WE HAVE ABOUT SECURITY ABOUT
CRIME AT THE NORCAL WAR THAT WE
HAVE IN MEXICO BUT I WOULD
POINT TO ONE ADDITIONAL PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE IN THIS USE YOUR
SYSTEM. WE DON'T HAVE THE
INSTITUTIONAL CULTURE. TO
PROMOTE STUDY ABROAD FOR OUR
STUDENTS IN MEXICO AND I'LL
TELL YOU WHY. THERE'S THREE
CENTERS THREE CITIES IN SPAIN
WHERE EVEN LATINOS EVEN HE
CONDOS RATHER TO GO TO STUDY
SPANISH AS SOMEBODY WAS TELLING
ME EARLIER THIS MORNING THAT.
BUT FEEL WAS TELLING ME THAT
THAT ONE OF HIS FRIENDS
SWINTON'S DINNERS SPANISH IN IN
IN IN SPAIN. AND THEN YOU COME
BACK SPEAKING IN A RARE HER IS
NOT THE CULTURAL CONTEXT IS NOT
THE KIND OF SPANISH. THAT WE
ARE MORE LIKELY TO USE IN THE
CLASSROOM AS TEACHERS OR IN ANY
PROFESSIONAL FEEL. SO NOT
WITHSTANDING THIS REALITY BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS CLOSEST ONE AUDIO AND
GIVE IT KNOWN WHO HAVE NOW BOTH
ARE I DON'T I DON'T THE
LEGISLATURE SPONSOR A AT IT HE-
JOINT RESOLUTION AN ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION NUMBER
ONE FORTY SIX. THEY RECOGNIZE
THE CALIFORNIA MEXICO PROJECT
THAT I STAB US A CAL STATE LONG
BEACH BUT ALSO THE DIRECTED FOR
THE CALIFORNIA RESEARCH BE
YOURS TO CONDUCT THE STUDY. IT
REPORT CAUGHT ON CALIFORNIA
MAKES YOU STUDY BETTER PROGRAMS
JUST BE NORMAL IS. MORE THAN
TEN YEARS AND I WILL CALL UPON
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE SENATORS
THAT HERE TO RE VISIT THAT AND
TO BRING YOU UP TO DATE. FOR
THE CALIFORNIA RESEARCH BUREAU
TO UP THE SPEAKERS HOW ARE WE
DOING AND NOT ONLY CAL STATE
BUT YET THE UC AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BECAUSE
THERE'S GREAT. LESSONS TO BE.
LEARNED FROM THAT THAT RESEARCH
THAT WAS DONE. AND I USE WHEN
IT COME THROUGH BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT I DON'T WANT TO TAKE MORE
THAN THE FIVE MINUTES ALLOCATED
THE REPORT IS. POINTS TO A LOT
OF THE- OBVIOUS. DEVELOPMENT
RESOURCES NEED TO BE APPLIED
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE THE
FOLLOWING RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
THE COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER. THE
WAVE THAT THAT THAT THAT THAT
THE GOVERNOR IS LEANING. AT
THIS POINT IS A FANTASTIC
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE COMMITTEE
TO EXPAND COLLABORATION WITH
CAL FOR COMPETING CALIFORNIA
MEXICO'S COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IT IS ALSO A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO CONVENE A
CONFERENCE THAT COULD DEVELOP
JOIN UP I MEAN AND- VENTURES
THAT COULD EXPAND THIS ACADEMIC
EXCHANGE. AND THEN ALSO THE
FACT THAT WHAT WE NEED IS TO
DEVELOP GREATER COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE INSTITUTIONS TO
EXCHANGE FACULTY AND STUDENTS
HAVE FOR THAT I ALSO PROPOSE IN
THIS PAPER. THE CONSTABLE BY
ONE TO ONE EXCHANGE BETWEEN
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW YOU CAN
ELIMINATE THE OUT OF STATE
TUITION. IF YOU WISH EXCHANGE
STUDENT FROM A MEXICAN
UNIVERSITY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTION NEITHER ONE HAS TO
PAY FOR OUT OF STATE TUITION
BUT AGAIN THESE ARE LONG TERM
IDEAS AND RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
ARE IN THE PAPER. AND AGAIN I
THINK YOU FOR GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO DAY AND TOO WELL
SHARE SOME OF THESE CONCEPTS.
AND IDEAS FOR THE AUDIENCE
THINK SO MUCH. GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH PROFESSOR
EDMUNDO VASQUEZ FOR REALLY
SETTING UP THE CHALLENGES AND
THE ISSUES THAT WE ARE FACING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN OUR PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS AS HE SO
ELOQUENTLY SAD WE SHARE THE
SAME CHALLENGES BE IT WITHIN
THE YOU SEE THE CAL STATE AND
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT IF IT WASN'T
BECAUSE OF OUR FACULTY AND
YOU'LL HEAR THIS IN A MOMENT
WHEN I GIVE MY PRESENTATION.
OUR FACULTY ARE REALLY THE
DRIVERS FOR OUR OUR FACULTY
EXCHANGES AND BEFORE YOU GET
INTO MY TALK ONE THING I WANTED
TO SHARE WITH OUR OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM VISIT
CALIFORNIA AND WHAT NOT IS
THROUGH OUR INSTITUTIONS YOU
HAVE AN ACCESS AND THE VENUE OF
BEING ABLE TO BUILD UP
ADDITIONAL TRAVEL OPPORTUNITIES
SO FOR EXAMPLE HAKU WHICH IS
THE HISPANIC ASSOCIATION OF
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES IN
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THEY'RE GOING TO BE HERE IN SAN
DIEGO. SO IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY
TO VISIT THIS BUYING NATIONAL
VISIT AND TO SEE HOW WE CAN
ENGAGE WITH T. ONE ENSENADA AND
OUR OTHER EDUCATIONAL SYSTEMS
HERE IN. ALONG THE BORDER. AND
BUT JUST TO THROW THAT OUT.
OKAY SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT MORE
PERSPECTIVE UP UNTIL TWENTY
FIFTEEN. ANY KIND OF ACTIVITY
THAT WAS TAKING PLACE IN TERMS
OF ACADEMIC MOBILITY THIS
STUDENT FACULTY STAFF GOING
BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA AND MEXICO HE WAS
PRIMARILY BEING DRIVEN AT
WITHIN THE YOU SEE BY OUR
FACULTY BY OUR CAMPUSES. IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN THERE WAS A
AGREEMENT SIGNED BETWEEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND PRESIDENT
OPINION YET SO. THAT IT'S
CALLED FOR BESSIE. IT IS
BASICALLY A BI NATIONAL
AGREEMENT FOR EDUCATION
INNOVATION TECHNOLOGY. THAT
AGREEMENT CREATED A SYSTEM WHAT
I MEAN BILATERAL FINANCIAL
PERSPECTIVE OF ENGAGEMENT THAT
TO THIS DAY IS THE FOUNDING
PRINCIPAL OF THE UC MEXICO
INITIATIVE. WHAT IS IMPORTANT
ABOUT THIS IS WE ARE FOR
EXAMPLE WITHIN THE UC SYSTEM WE
STARTED TO TRACK OUR ACADEMIC
MOBILITY TO MEXICO AS A SYSTEM
THAT'S OUR TEN CAMPUSES ARE
NATIONAL LABS AS WELL AS OUR
MEDICAL SCHOOLS. WE ROSE WE
GAINED 37% INCREASE IN MOBILITY
BECAUSE WE FOCUSED ON THIS FOR
BESSIE AS OUR PLATFORM. I'M
BRINGING THIS UP BECAUSE IT IS
AN EXAMPLE AND CALIFORNIA IS
NOT THE ONLY ONE I AM SURE THAT
CONSUL GENERAL CONSENSUS CAN
GIVE YOU EXAMPLES TO OF TEXAS
AND WHAT NOT. IT HAS CREATED IT
OPEN WIDE THE DOORS AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES IT IS THROUGH
FIVE S. YOU THAT I HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO WORK WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE CAL STATE AS
WELL IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SO I JUST WANTED TO THROW THAT
OUT THERE. THAT THAT TYPE OF
ENGAGEMENT WERE THAT KIND OF
SUPPORT IS BROUGHT OUT
CALIFORNIA CAN BE A LEADER WE
ALREADY HAD THIS WITH PRESIDENT
OBAMA I THINK THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY. FOR CALIFORNIA TO
EXPLORE. AS I MENTIONED WE DO
HAVE CULTURAL AND EDUCATIONAL
TOURISM THIS IS THE BRASS OF A
GLOBAL ENGAGEMENT THIS IS OUR
WHAT WE PROMOTE AND WHAT WE
PUSH THIS IS THE FUTURE THAT WE
WANT FOR OUR STUDENTS. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS KIND OF BY NATIONAL TRAVEL
BE IT HERE AT THE BORDER AS
WELL AS FURTHER INLAND MAINLAND
FROM BOTH REGIONS IT IS A
FOUNDING PRINCIPLE FOR THE TYPE
OF FUTURE TALENT. WORKERS AND
INDIVIDUALS AND CONTRIBUTORS
THAT WE WANT IN OUR SOCIETY. WE
HAVE STUDENTS WERE GOING BACK
AND FORTH AS YOU OBVIOUSLY KNOW
TO PURSUE THEIR GRADUATE
DEGREES. WE CURRENTLY WILL BE
HOSTING IN FEB YOUR I MEAN
WELCOME MEAN THIS SOUNDED THIS
SEPTEMBER MORE THAN A HUNDRED
SIXTY GRADUATE STUDENTS WHO
WILL BE COMING INTO THE USER
SEES ALL OF THE TEN UC CAMPUSES
WE ARE CURRENTLY HERE IN SAN
DIEGO AT UC SAN DIEGO HOSTING
MORE THAN HUNDRED TEN
UNDERGRADUATES FROM MEXICO. WHO
ARE PARTICIPATING IN A SUMMER
RESEARCH INTERNSHIP PROGRAM. WE
ALSO ARE HOST STEAM AND
SEPTEMBER A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF TRIPPING OVER
SLOWLY COMING TO GET FAMILIAR
WITH CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
SYSTEMS THEY WILL BE PRIMARILY
VISITING. RIVERSIDE AND UC
DAVIS BUT ALL ALONG THE WAY
THEY WILL BE STOPPING TO DO
VISITS THROUGHOUT GETTING TO
MOVE BE BECOME MORE FAMILIAR
WITH THE WAY OUR AGRICULTURE
SYSTEMS ARE INTEGRATED WITH THE
UNIVERSITY AND HOW THERE IS
THAT CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
PRIVATE. AND THE PUBLIC SECTOR.
IN ADDITION TO THAT IT'S THESE
TYPE OF AGREEMENTS THESE TYPE
OF MOBILITY OPPORTUNITIES THAT
ALLOW US TO REALLY BE ABLE TO
BUILD A PROGRAM. SO BEFORE
TWENTY FOURTEEN. THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA ALL OF OUR
CAMPUSES HATTIE PROGRAM HAD
SOME KIND OF ENGAGEMENT WITH
MEXICO BUT IT WASN'T UNTIL
TWENTY FOURTEEN. THAT WE
STARTED TO LOOK WHAT CAN WE DO
AS A SYSTEM SO INSTEAD OF DOING
IT CAMPUS BY CAMPUS HOW COULD
WE LOOK AND BRING TOGETHER ANY
GREAT. OPPORTUNITIES ACROSS
THIS THE SYSTEM AND BE ABLE TO
WORK WITH OUR COLLEAGUES IN
MEXICO TO REALLY ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES. AND OPPORTUNITIES
THAT WE HAVE ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE BORDER. AND SO IS AS SUCH
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO
COLLABORATIONS WITH OF BEING A
SECRETARY AT THE MINISTRY OF
ENERGY AND TWENTY SIXTEEN WE
WERE ABLE TO DO A SIX PLUS
MILLION DOLLAR. GRANT SYSTEM
WITH THEM WHERE WE WERE ABLE TO
ENCOURAGE INTEGRATION BETWEEN
OUR MEXICO UNIVERSITIES AND UC
CAMPUSES TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS.
CLEAN ENERGY ENERGY EFFICIENT
OPPORTUNITIES WE CURRENTLY HAVE
SOME OF YOU I DON'T KNOW I KNOW
THAT THOSE FROM FROM UP NORTH
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH UC DAVIS
WE HAVE A TOP OF THE LINE.
ENERGY LIKE EFFICIENCY CENTER
WELL WE ARE NOW BUILDING WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES IN MEXICO THE
UNIVERSITY OF GUADALAJARA. AS
ART THE DIRECTOR THERE SAYS A
BETTER SYSTEM THAT IS NOW
INTEGRATED SO THIS IS A UC
DAVIS UNIVERSITY OF GUADALAJARA
RESEARCH ENERGY EFFICIENCY
LIGHT CENTER THAT WILL BE TOP
OF THE LINE. THAT WILL BE
BENEFICIAL TO BOTH REGIONS. AS
I MENTIONED WE DO. IT'S OUR
FACULTY ENGAGEMENT THAT THAT
REALLY HAS BEEN THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL WE DO HAVE THE
TRADITIONAL EDUCATION ABROAD
PROGRAM. FOR THE YOU SEE IT'S
PRIMARILY OR NON INSTEAD OF THE
TECH DEMO TODAY. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS WE WANT TO DO IS WE WANT
TO SPIN IT WE WANT TO STOP JUST
LOOKING AT THIS ONE ON ONE
RECIPROCAL AND WE WANT TO
RETHINK. WHAT ARE THE BEST WAYS
OF BEING ABLE TO DO EXCHANGES
SPEED VERY SHORT TERM BE IT
JUST FOR A COUPLE OF WEEKS TO
POTENTIALLY SIX YEARS FOR WHEN
A STUDENT IS PROTECT IS
PURSUING THEIR GRADUATE DEGREE.
IN ADDITION TO THAT YOU MAY BE
FAMILIAR TO UP ARE YOU SEEM
NEXUS THIS IS THE UC INSTITUTE
FOR MEXICO IN THE UNITED STATES
IT HAS MADE MORE THAN THIRTY
YEAR HISTORY. OF WORKING WITH
MEXICO SPECIALLY CONTEST SEAT
WHICH IS THE EQUIVALENT OF OUR
NATIONAL SCIENCE FOUNDATION.
THEY HAVE SPONSORED MORE THAN
FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX.
GRADUATE STUDENTS THESE ARE
MEXICO UNIVERSITY STUDENTS WHO
HAVE COME UP COMPLETED THEIR
MASTER'S AND PHD. FIVE HUNDRED
AND NINETY SIX WE HAVE MORE
THAN EIGHT HUNDRED FACULTY
RESEARCH COLLABORATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN SPONSORED. THESE ARE
THE BASS LINES AS TO WHAT
CONTINUES THE DIALOGUE AT AN
EDUCATIONAL LEVEL AND A
CULTURAL EXCHANGE LEVEL BETWEEN
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WAIT
WHAT AS MISTER GORE WELL GORE
TO LET HERE STILL ALL THERE YOU
ARE WE HAVE A QUESTION
REGARDING FLIGHTS AND WHAT
FLIGHTS ARE CHOSEN AT AIRPORTS
AND OUR OUR MAYOR WANTS TO KNOW
ABOUT THE FILIPINO COMMUNITY.
THERE WE HAVE ONE OF THE
LARGEST FILIPINO COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA HERE LOCALLY IN HERE
ESPECIALLY IN. EITHER AND THE
QUESTION AS FLIGHTS TO MANILA
OR THE PHILIPPINES WHY ISN'T
THAT SOMETHING THAT HAS HAS
FIFTY ONE AIRPORT LOOKED AT
THAT AS A POTENTIAL ROUTE. AND
IS THAT SOMETHING IS POSSIBLE.
I'M GOING TO BE. SO MID
SEPTEMBER THERE'S A BIG
CONFERENCE WERE AIRLINES AND
AIRPORTS MEET TO SCHOOLS ROUTES
IN THIS TRIAL YEAH I'M GOING TO
BE PART OF THAT THE WHOLE FOCUS
OF GROUP BY REPORTER THE
PACIFIC CALL WILL BE ON THE CBS
ON THESE TRANS BORDER CROSSING
WE'RE MEETING WITH TOP
PHILIPPINE AIRLINES SOMEONE
AROUND THIRTEEN OTHER CARRIERS
TO TRY TO ATTRACT MORE WILL
COMPETE WOULD SEND THE WRONG ON
THAT BUT I CAN. THE GOALIES
ANYWAY BRING MORE MORE AIR
SERVICE INTO THE INTO THE
REGION SAW HOPE I COME I COME
REVIEWED SEE THIS ALARM PROCESS
AND SOMETHING REMARKABLE THAT I
WANT TO MENTION THE QUANTITY OR
POOR WILLIAM BEST CLOSE TO A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
NEXT FEW YEARS. TO DEVELOP A
NEW FACILITY WHICH WILL ALLOW
INTERNATIONAL THE INBOUND PASS
ON YOURS TO CROSS THE WRIGLEY
THROUGH THE UNITED STATES
WITHOUT ENTERING INTO MEXICAN
VICE SERVER SO THAT WILL WE
CONVERT A TRULY BY NATIONAL
FACILITY CV X. ON THE ONE OR-
NOT SINCE WHAT IS HERE. WITH
YOUR WHERE DOES THE CHECK I YOU
KNOW MAYBE THIS IS A QUESTION
MATTERED BETTER HAD YOU KNOW IN
PRIVATE BUT I WAS WONDERING
WHAT ARE THEIR KIND OF TENSIONS
BUT ALSO SYNERGIES WITH SAN
DIEGO AIRPORT AND THE- YOU KNOW
WITH WITH THIS DEVELOPMENT
LOOKED UPON AS A AS A NEGATIVE
IS A POSITIVE WITH REGARDS TO
SENIOR PROM TENSIONS. WELL I
WOULDN'T SAY THAT DO AWFUL SAID
WE'RE WORKING TOGETHER WE'RE
ABOUT 2% OF PROJECT WORK WE CAN
FACILITATE. THAT TRANSFER OF
PASSENGERS BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTAND. THE ONE I DON'T
WANT WON'T HAVE FLIGHTS INTO
THE US AND HE WILL BE VERY
DIFFICULT THAT SENT VIA WILL
GET. FLY SEEM TO MEXICO JUST
BECAUSE THE TAXATION PROCESS ON
AND IT'S COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
PLANE DOMESTIC THINGS VERSUS
INTERNATIONAL SO WE'RE WORKING.
WITH THEM NINETEEN AT THE
BEGINNING THAT'S A WAS VERY
SIMILAR TO THE QUAN ASK PEOPLE
WHEN WE LEARN CV X. THEY EXPECT
THAT WE WILL STEAL. PASSENGERS
GETTING INTO THE ONE AND THAT
HAS NOT BEEN THE CASE. THESE
WERE WORKING AND COLLABORATE
TOGETHER WOULD SEND THE OR TO
COMPLEMENT EACH OTHER NETWORK.
AND THE YOU KNOW WITH THE WORK
AND FOR WELL OVER TWENTY YEARS
TO SIDE A NEW AIRPORT. IN SAN
DIEGO BUT WE WERE IN
COMPETITION WITH. SOME MILITARY
AIRFIELDS OR OF STRATEGIC
IMPORTANCE TO THE COUNTRY AND
THEY TAKE UP A LOT OF. REAL
ESTATE IN OUR COUNTY. THAT
INCLUDES CAMP PENDLETON NORTH
ISLAND AND MIRAMAR RIGHT SO YOU
SO RIGHT NOW SO WHEN YOU WE
LOOK AT THE AIR TRAVEL WE'VE
LOOKED AT. WE HAVE BROWN FIELD
WHICH IS AN INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT HERE NO TIME MESA BUT
IT HAS LIMITATIONS BASED ON THE
MOUNTAIN RANGE AND SO THE
GEOGRAPHY. IN SENEGAL MAKES IT
VERY HARD TO CITE AN AIRPORT.
WHICH MEANS THE RIGHT NOW SAN
DIEGO IS THE BUSIEST ONE RUNWAY
AIRPORT IN THE NATION. AND SO
THE WHOLE HAVING A RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE QUANAH WORKS OUT VERY
WELL FOR US BECAUSE IT GIVES
MORE OPTIONS TO TRAVELERS. TO
TRAVEL FROM INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT WITH DESTINATIONS I
CONNECT WITH THE REST OF THE
WORLD. IN AREAS THAT SENDING
WHAT DOES NOT PROVIDE SO THIS
WHAT SENEGAL HAS. IN AN OPTIONS
DEPENDS ON WHAT THE WANNA HAS
SO IT'S BEEN ACTUAL
RELATIONSHIP THAT'S WORKED VERY
WELL FOR OUR REGION. AND
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE LOOKING TO
EXPAND. THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
THAT WAS A GOOD ANSWER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE'RE GONNA
BRING OUR NEXT A PANEL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE
AND FOR YOUR COMMENTS. OUR NEXT
PANEL HAS TO DO WITH HEALTH
CARE AND HEALTH CARE. HE IS
ALSO A BIG INDUSTRY NOT ONLY
ONLY IN CALIFORNIA AND MEXICO
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF UNIQUE
RELATIONSHIPS. WHAT THE HEALTH
CARE RESOURCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
BORDER. WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT
HOW THAT IS IMPORTANT TO OUR-
NO ALL NOT ONLY ARE COOKED A
CONDOM ME BUT TO THE WELL BEING
OF THE PEOPLE OF OUR STATE AND
HOW ALSO FOR SERVICE CITY IN.
THIS REGION BECAUSE OF THE-
HEALTH CARE RESOURCES THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE SO WE HAVE FRANK
ARE YOU. HE IS THE C. E. O. OF.
A SYSTEM MUST MEDICALS
NATIONALISTS ALSO KNOWN LOCALLY
AS SOME SO. HE IS PROVIDE
HEALTHCARE SERVICES. TO HIS HIS
CUSTOMER BASE IS LARGELY PEOPLE
LIVING IN THE UNITED STATES
MEXICAN ORIGIN THAT GO TO
PROVIDE A I'LL GET. HMO HMO
SERVICES IN MEXICO WE HAVE AN
ERRANT WOULD ANY OTHER DIRECTOR
OF MEDICAL TOURISM FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND CARLA
NASAL THEY HELP TO RESUME CEO
FOR THE NEW MEDICAL CITY LOTS
OF WELCOME AND WILL BEGIN WITH
A MISTER CURRY YOU'RE WELCOME
THANK THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU
SELLABAND WAS AND. THIS MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR HOLDING
THIS EVENT. VERY IMPORTANT. I
KNOW WE'RE RUNNING LATE.
GETTING HUNGRY PEOPLE LOSING
WE'RE LOSING AUDIENCE SO HAD
HIT THERE SO BEFORE WE I STAND
HERE BY MYSELF I THINK A BETTER
BETTER HURRY. WHEN I TALK ABOUT
THE SAME SIZE SAME SON ISM
COMPANY THAT WAS BORN IN IN IN
THE CORNER. YEAH IN THE LATE
NINETIES SEEMS A BECAME
LICENSED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FIRST FIRST MEXICAN
COMPANY. IN HEALTHCARE THERE
WAS ADMIT IT. THE CALIFORNIA IS
THE LICENSE HMO. AND WE START
I'M THE FOUNDER WE STARTED IT
AND ZERO AND NOW WE HAVE ABOUT
SEVENTY THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS.
THERE IS ANOTHER HEALTH PLAN IS
SIMILAR TO OURS A LITTLE SMALL
THEY THEY THEY THEY JUST BECAME
LICENSE ABOUT SIX SEVEN YEARS
AGO SO IN ALL WE PROVIDE
SERVICE TO ABOUT 800-009-0000
SUBSCRIBERS ALL OF WHOM ARE
RESIDENTS OF US IN THE
ACCOUNTING IN IMPERIAL COUNTY
THOSE ARE THE TWO COUNTIES THAT
WE SERVICE. SAME SIZE THE
LARGEST OF COURSE WE WOULD BEEN
IN BUSINESS ALL OVER TWENTY
YEARS ALREADY BASIC SAYS FULLY
WE'VE BEEN GROWING AND GROWING
WE ARE THE EXCLUSIVE PROVIDERS
OF ANTHEM AT NINE HEALTH MAN.
WHICH ALSO PROVIDE TRANS BORDER
HEALTH THEY HAVE SPECIFIC PLANS
THAT THAT PROVIDE SERVICES IN
MEXICO. AND TRANSPORTER HEALTH
IS IT'S A WIN WIN FOR BOTH
SIDES OF THE BORDER OF COURSE
FOR MEXICO IS THE A GREAT
GENERATOR OF INCOME. ONE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN REVENUE
YEARLY. BUT IT'S A WIN ALSO FOR
THE SIDE OF THE BORDER. IN THAT
PEOPLE CAN FIND AFFORDABLE
HEALTH CARE THAT OTHERWISE
PROBABLY WOULDN'T WOULDN'T HAVE
WOULDN'T GET. FRIENDLY AND I
THINK IT'S HIGH QUALITY AS WELL.
AS FAR AS THE HMO. WE HAVE
CONTRACTS WITH ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED EMPLOYER GROUPS ON BOTH
AND BOTH KIND OF SAN DIEGO AND
IMPERIAL COUNTY'S ABOUT 70%
HERE IN THE SAN DIEGO AREA.
COMPANIES LIKE GENERAL DYNAMICS
MAREA KILLED THEN ALMOST EVERY
MAJOR HOTEL. IS A MEMBER OF
SENSOR ALL THE CASINOS IN SAN
DIEGO AS WELL. IN LABOR UNIONS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. AND EVERY WE
HAVE MANY MANY VARIOUS. TYPE OF
INDUSTRIES. HOW DO HOW DO THEY
WIN. THEY SAVE MONEY ON
PREMIUMS. OUR PREMIUMS ABOUT
ONE HALF OF WHAT THEY ARE ON
THE SIDE OF THE BORDER AND FOR
THE SAME SERVICE. AND. SO WE
ARE FILLING A VACUUM THOSE
THOSE SAVINGS OF COURSE GO
TOWARDS PROVIDING CARE FOR
OTHER EMPLOYEES. SO IT'S A IT'S
A BLESSING THIS THING IS A WIN
WIN FOR EVERYONE. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE MEDICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE WINNER BY
CALIFORNIA IS. ALWAYS GROWING
AND GROWING AND AN EXAMPLE OF
THAT. IS A VIDEO THAT WE HAVE
THEY WILL SHOW OUR LATEST
VENTURE WHICH IS A HOSPITAL WE
WERE BUILDING A HOSPITAL THAT
WILL BE COMPLETED IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WITH AN INVESTMENT
OF ABOUT A HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS. AND OUR
INVESTMENT IS ONLY ONE PART OF
THE WHOLE INVESTMENT. IN THIS
CITY THE PERSON THAT IS HERE
REPRESENTING HIM BUT NOT
ALTOGETHER I THINK WE'RE
INVESTING ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THAT SCENE IF
YOU WANNA. SO LET'S PLAY THE
VIDEO. THIS WILL BE A ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY BED HOSPITAL
THAT IS BEING BUILT. RIGHT
AROUND THE MEDICAL CENTER THAT
WE HAVE WE IT SEEMS AS THOUGH
IT WAS LIKE A KAISER MODEL. WE
ARE THE INSURANCE AS WELL AS
THE AT THE PROVIDERS OF CARE WE
HAVE A FOUR HUNDRED PHYSICIANS
IN OUR IN OUR NETWORK. IN ABOUT
SIX HUNDRED EMPLOYEES. THIS
ISN'T THE ONE THAT IS RIGHT
ACROSS THE BORDER ABOUT. EIGHT
A AND IRON THE TO IRON SHOT
FROM UP ON THE BORDER. LAST IN
TERMS IN TERMS OF GOLF BUT LIKE
WITH THE TORN ANYMORE. IS IT IS
THREE HUNDRED YARDS. WE HAVE
PARKING PARKING SPACES THERE
FOR TWELVE HUNDRED VEHICLES
ALREADY BUILT. AND THIS IS HOW
THE HOUSE WAS BEGINNING TO LOOK
YOU CAN ALREADY SEE GO AND SEE
THAT IT'S BEGINNING TO SHAPE UP
ALREADY. THE AND RIGHT IN THE
CENTER OF THIS BUILDING SAYING
WE HAVE A MEDICAL CENTER SO
THIS NOT ONLY WILL BE A
HOSPITAL THERE WILL BE ALSO AN
OUTPATIENT MEDICAL CENTER THE
LARGEST DENTAL OFFICE CENTER
BEDFORD I THINK YOU YOU YOU
WERE YOU WERE ENQUIRING ABOUT
THE INDUSTRY. WE HAVE ABOUT
FIFTY DENTISTS WORKING IN THAT
A LITTLE BIT OFFICE. LITTLE
CENTER. YEAH WE PROVIDE NOT
ONLY MEDICALLY NECESSARY
SERVICES BUT ALSO CLASS MANIC
WE HAVE A SPA. WE HAVE
REGENERATIVE MEDICINE INCLUDING
STEM CELL THERAPY. SO WE WAY
WAY AHEAD OF. EVERYONE ELSE.
VERY BEAUTIFUL FACILITY. THEY
WILL BE PROVIDING EVERYTHING
THAT IS MEDICALLY NEEDED
INCLUDING CARDIOLOGY
TRANSPLANTS HOPEFULLY IT'LL BE
ALSO AN INVESTIGATIVE. HOSPITAL
WE'LL HAVE INVESTIGATIONS WELL.
A LOT OF OPEN AIR SPACES WE
FEEL THAT. IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
FOR HEALING THEN THEY FEEL THAT
IF THEY'RE NOT IN THE HOSPITAL
THERE AND THAT WE SUPPORT IT IS
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE IT WILL LOOK
LIKE A RESTART. WITH THE WITH
THE SHOPPING CENTER INSIDE.
THEY WILL HAVE BEAUTY SHOPS.
PHARMACIES. MANY MANY OTHER
THINGS INCLUDED. WE HAVE SIX
SEVEN THERE IS THIS. BEAUTIFUL
RESTAURANT TWENTY FOUR HOUR
EMERGENCY CARE. SO THIS
FACILITY CAN EASILY COMPETE
WITH ANY ANY OTHER HOSPITAL IN
THE IN THIS REGION. WE'RE
BUILDING IT SO THAT SO THAT
IT'LL IT'LL HAVE. THE BE
COMPETITIVE WITH ANY ANY
FACILITY IN IN THE WORLD. THANK
YOU. SOLD SO WELL I THINK IT'LL
PLAY FOR ANOTHER TWO OR THREE
MINUTES BUT I THINK OF A CLOSE
IT NOW SO THAT I CAN. ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AND WE CAN GO ANY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK. NO
ONE WANTS TO. ERIN I DON'T KNOW
WELL THEN YEAH. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE. HM IN THIS VERY
IMPORTANT REUNION IT IS A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE IN. MEET
EVERYONE. I WONDER TO START
WITH A SHORT VIDEO. MANUALS
BELIEVE HAPPENING THIS WEEKEND
I MESSED UP MY TOOTH WENT TO
THE DENTIST NOW THEN SHARON
STONE COVER IT I GOT A CO PAY I
DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M GONNA DO.
AND. SORRY TO HEAR THAT. I ALSO
WENT TO THE DENTIST. HE WAS
PRETTY COOL
. LOOK. YES THAT'S A
GREAT AT HEALTH AND WELLNESS.
THIS IS THE HOTEL FOR NOW. IN
THIS PRESENTATION A. I WONDER
TOO TO SHOW YOU THE CRAWL. ALL
THE MEDICAL TOURISM IN OUR
STATE AND HOW THE PUBLIC POLICY.
HOUSE COLLABORATE TO IT LAST
YEAR. THE SAFETY AND THE TRUST
OF A REGION. SO THE NEXT SORT.
YOU CAN SEE ON THE MAP. WE SHOW
YOU THE SOULS BY STATE. A WERE
MAINLY IN MEDICAL AT THE STORES
WE RECEIVE IS HIGH THE PERSON
THAT SHE'S COMING FROM
CALIFORNIA 49% AND THEN TWENTY
7% IS FROM A RESULT. OKAY A.
THE MOTLEY OPERATION OF A DOG
BE STORY AND MEDICAL TOURISM IN
BAJA CALIFORNIA IS THAT ABOUT
TWO THOUSAND AND IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND-
DOLLARS. AND THE OTHER IS TO
THE STICK THEM MOSTLY 40% OF
THE ABC DOLLARS IS PANIC AND
ABOUT A 10% IS IT A CLASSIC AND
THE AND THE 10% OF CANADIAN AS
WELL. ONE TWENTY SIXTEEN TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION OF PATIENT
AND COMPANION. A B. C. THE BAJA
CALIFORNIA. THANKS FOR THAT OFF
THE STATUS THEY INCOME IS EIGHT
EIGHT HUNDRED AND MERELY ON A
DOLLAR FOR THE SET FOR MEDICAL
TREATMENT. ON TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
EIGHTEEN WE HAVE. A INCOME FOR
ONE THOUSAND MILLION OF DOLLAR.
ALSO I'M VERY GRATEFUL TO
MENTION THAT ON THIS YEAR WE
ARE OUR SECOND PLACE IN MEDICAL
TERMS IN THE GLOBAL. I'M VERY
PROUD TO. TO MENTION BAJA
CALIFORNIA IS THE FIRST AT THE
PIONEER. STATE IN MEXICO
WITHOUT PUBLIC POLICY. FOR HELP
TOWARDS THE BOTTOM. WHICH
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY IS TO
PROVIDE SAFETY AND PROTECTION
FOR THE PATIENT AND THE
COMPANION. AT THE END OF THE
SEVENTH EDITION WE WILL LIKE TO
ENCOURAGE TO START BY NATIONAL
PROP FOR. TO ALLOW OR DOCTORS
FOR MEXICO AND THE US HAVE
ACCESS FOR THE PATIENT MEDICAL
RECORD. UNDER THE MOST
HISTORICALLY INTERNATIONAL
PROTOCOLS IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
THE PROPER MEDICAL CARE IN
FOLLOW UP. IN BOTH SIDES OF THE
BORDER. THIS IS FOR WARRANTY
THAT PATIENT TRUST AND SAFETY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
HELLO THANKS FOR THE INVITATION
I AM VERY PROUD AND HONORED TO
REPRESENT AND USE IT TO MEDICAL
PLAZA IN THE NAME OF ABOUT A
FAMILY. AND ESPECIALLY IN THE
SOUTH PART OF JOINING PRIVATE
ENTERPRISE AND PUBLIC EFFORTS
TO DO THESE ARE REALITY. SO IF
CAN YOU PUT THE PRESENTATION
PLEASE I'M GONNA TAKE JUST TWO
MINUTES. HM I HAVE BEEN IN THIS
INDUSTRY AROUND THREE YEARS
REALLY UNDERSTANDING HOW TO
CREATE A SERVICE THAT IS NOT
BILINGUAL BUT BY CULTURE OUT.
IT WE REALLY DO UNDERSTAND
THINGS IN A DIFFERENT WAY EVEN
IF WE SPEAK THE SAME LANGUAGE
SO A ONE THING THAT A WITH
THESE VERY PROFOUNDLY IT'S A
STUDY IN THE STATES. TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WHICH ONES WERE
THE PILLARS TO CREATE THIS
BUSINESS. AND ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT ONES IS REALLY
INTEGRATING THE SERVICE AMONG
THREE SOME AND MEDICAL. WHEN
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT THREE
SOME WE KNOW IT'S ADVENTURES. I
DON'T HAVE DON'T WORRY NO WORRY
SO WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT TO
RESUME ITS ADVENTURE WHEN YOU
TOOK OUT A TALK ABOUT MEDICAL.
A PEOPLE FEEL VULNERABLE SO IT
LOOKS LIKE THE VERY OPPOSITE
TORCHED WORDS TO PUT TOGETHER.
SO THE PEELER SAID WE FIND OUT
THAT WERE VERY IMPORTANT IS
THAT THE PATIENTS IN THE STATES
REALLY WANT TO HAVE AN
INTEGRATED SERVICE SOMEBODY
THAT FULLY ADVOCATES FOR THEM
AND RESPOND FOR THEM. RIGHT NOW
A SOME COMPANIES AS SEEMS ARE
DOING AMAZINGLY BECAUSE THEY
INTEGRATE SERVICES BUT IT'S NOT
THE REALITY OF HOW THIS IS
HAPPENING IN MEXICO. SO ONE
THING THAT WE NEED TO CREATE IS
REALLY THE QUALITY THAT YOU
EXPECT US AT AM AMERICAN
PATIENT. BUT WITH THE- THE BEST
OF BOTH WORLDS THAT WE ARE
HEARING THE BORDER TO HAVE
INSURANCE IN A DIFFERENT COST A
SEEMS IS DOING. AND THE QUALITY
OF SERVICE SO I THINK THAT THE
SIX OF AN AMAZING OPPORTUNITY
THE BUILDING OFF OF MEDICAL
PLAZA IT'S TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
METERS OF DIFFERENT MEDICAL
SPECIALITIES. WITH HOTEL THAT
IT'S ALREADY OPEN IT WITH
COMMERCIAL CENTERS FOR A FIVE
HUNDRED FIVE HUNDRED METERS
FROM THE BORDER. SO WE ARE
REALLY LOOKING UP TO ANOTHER
FACILITY OF THE QUALITY OF
SEEMS. AND REALLY TRYING TO DO
THINGS WITH THE GOVERNMENT IN A
DIFFERENT AND VERY PROFESSIONAL
WAY TO HAVE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH TO THE SCENE THE
STREET BECAUSE IT'S NEW. IT'S
NOT MATURE AND THERE'S A LOT OF
A OPPORTUNITIES. FOR ALL OF US
TO WORK IN THESE TWO GUYS THANK
YOU. THANKS ONLY ONE APOLOGIZE
WE WANT TO WE WENT OVER
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER ON TIME BUT
WE GOT THROUGH IT THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE THAT PARTICIPATED AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
AND I JUST WANTED TO IF ANYBODY
DIDN'T HAVE IF ANYBODY HAS ANY
QUESTIONS WE CAN OFFER THEM
NOW. AND IF ANYBODY IN THE
PUBLIC LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT
ALSO IF ANYBODY WANTS TO COME
FORWARD TO MAKE A COMMENT SIR
JUST COME UP TO THE MIKE AND TO
SHARE. GIVE US MAYBE A MINUTE
COMMON IF YOU COULD YES THERE
WELL FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU FOR
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER AS A
NATIVE OF THE ONE I MEAN WE'VE
SEEN OUR FAIR SHARE OF. BAD
PUBLICITY WE STILL SEE IT BUT
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THINGS I
MEAN YOU HEAR ABOUT US KNOW
YOUR NAME SO SORRY A DOCTOR
ARIEL ORTIZ I'M ALSO SURGEON. A
COLLEAGUE OF THE OF ALL OF US
MY FRIENDS HERE I HAVE A WEIGHT
LOSS SURGERY CENTER I'VE BEEN
IN THIS BUSINESS FOR TWENTY
YEARS MOSTLY DOING A COUPLE
THOUSAND SURGERIES PER YEAR. ON
US AND CANADIAN PATIENTS
TRAVELING TO MEXICO SO ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS THAT
WE'VE SEEN IS THAT EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE STILL OFFERING HIGH
QUALITY SERVICE IN CERTAIN
AREAS. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE ALSO SEEN LIKE I WAS
SAYING IS THAT THAT LESS THAN
IDEAL PUBLICITY ONCE IN AWHILE
WHEN THINGS DON'T GO AS WELL.
AND SPECIFICALLY TALKING ABOUT
THAT I WANT TO REFER TO THE
DOCTOR I DON'T KNOW DOING IT
BECAUSE I KNOW WE'VE BEEN
WORKING A LITTLE BIT TOGETHER
ON CREATING THIS CULTURE OF
ACCREDITATION IN MEXICO THE
ONLY WAY. YOU CAN GUARANTEE A
HIGH QUALITY HEALTH CARE
SERVICES NOT BY PATTING
YOURSELF ON THE BACK IN YOUR
ONLINE ADVERTISING BUT BY
ACTUALLY GETTING A THIRD PARTY
ACCREDITATION WHICH IS.
RESPECTED AROUND THE WORLD SUCH
LIKE JOIN COMMISSION
INTERNATIONAL. AND BECAUSE IT'S
A TRAVELING PATIENT NOW YOU
HAVE TO ADDRESS CERTAIN
ADDITIONAL ISSUES BECAUSE THE
PATIENT IS ACTUALLY TRAVELING
YOU WANT TO KEEP THEM SAFE YOU
WANT TO KEEP. THEIR FAMILY
MEMBER SAFE SO I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN A NEW ACCREDITATION THAT
JUST CAME ON ON BOARD WHICH IS
THE GLOBAL HEALTH CARE
ACCREDITATION THAT YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING ON DOCTOR LETTING IT SO
MAYBE HE COULD. COMMENT ON THAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE OKAY WELL THANK YOU WRAP
UP NOW MATT MADAM. YES PLEASE.
AT YES GO AHEAD. ALL SHE'S KIND
OF I JUST WANNA MAKE A QUICK
COMMENT AND RECOGNIZE A
PROFESSOR OF US. I'M GONNA TALK
MY DAUGHTER'S IN INTERNATIONAL
BUSINESS DEPARTMENT
SPECIALIZING IN SPANISH. AND
SHE CHOSE TO GO TO SPAIN BUT
THEIR FOR US IT WAS A PERSONAL
DECISION BECAUSE WE HAVE
FRIENDS THERE. BUT I'M GONNA
ASK FOR ONE WHEN I GET HOME
ABOUT IF MEXICO WAS PROMOTED AT
ALL WITHIN HER DEPARTMENT AND-
I'LL GIVE THAT INFORMATION BACK
TO THE CENTER AWAY SO THAT WE
CAN KEEP AN EYE ON. WHAT'S
GOING ON THERE SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION. THANK YOU.
HI I'M MY NAME IS REBECCA BY
YEAH LET ME GUESS I'M SIXTY
THREE YEARS OLD AND I'VE LIVED
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY MY WHOLE
LIFE. THE LAST THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS AND THE SOUTH BAY AND I
THANK YOU FOR THIS PRESENTATION
IT WAS VERY INFORMATIONAL AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE. EVERYTHING
THAT HAS BEEN DONE IN TERMS OF
TOURISM BAT ONE OF MY A.
CONCERNS WHETHER IT'S TOURISM.
OR IS ACTUALLY. A RESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA IT WAS INTERESTING I
THINK THAT MISS NEWTON
MENTIONED THAT AND ONE OF THE-
SURVEYS THAT WAS MENTIONED
ABOUT CALIFORNIA. THE IMAGE OF
CALIFORNIA BEING A FACTOR RATED
IN TERMS OF WHETHER TOURISTS
COME HERE. AND FROM THE TIME I
WAS LITTLE I'VE TRAVELED.
ACROSS THE BORDER IN TERMS OF
VISITING FAMILY IN ITS OUTSIDE
IN SIN NADA AND- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT IS SPECIALLY I'D
LIKE TO DIRECT TO OUR ELECTED
OFFICIALS. I'M IS THE ISSUE OF
SECURITY. NOT ONLY IN MEXICO IN
TERMS OF THE BORDER. I'LL I
HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS THAT LIVE
IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF MEXICO
AND THAT IS A REAL CONCERN THE
SAFETY I THE CRIME AND
CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF MY
HUSBAND AND I TRAVEL CROSS
COUNTRY THIS SUMMER. AND
HONESTLY I ONE OF THE IMAGES OF
CALIFORNIA IS WE ARE NOT A LAW
AND ORDER STATE. AND I THINK.
WE NEED TO PUT. ACTION IN TERMS
OF HAVING OUR STATE BE A STATE
THAT PROTECTS THE PEOPLE THAT
EITHER COME HERE AS VISITORS OR
THAT LIVE HERE SINCE I'VE BEEN
HERE FOR THIRTY SEVEN YEARS IN
THE SOUTH BAY WE'VE HAD THREE
VEHICLES STARTING LINE AND LET
ME JUST FINISH PLEASE YEAH BUT
I IT'S A ONE MINUTE AND I'VE
ALREADY GIVEN YOU TODAY OKAY SO
IF YOU COULD JUST THINK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
AND I WOULD JUST WANNA. BOB
FINISH UP BY YOU KNOW THANK YOU
EVERYBODY AND AS- I'M WORKING
ON TWO BILLS THAT WILL ONE WILL
CREATE A CALIFORNIA MEXICO
COMMISSION THE IDEA IS TO. GET
A CITIZENS COMMISSION INVOLVED
AND RESOLVING SOME OF THE-
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE SHARE IN
AND REALIZING AND ALSO COMING
UP WITH. A LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO SOME OF THESE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CONNECT ON.
ALSO THAT'S SP FIVE FIVE EIGHT
AND I'M ALSO PROPOSING.
ESTABLISHING A CALIFORNIA
OFFICE IN MEXICO IT'S NOT.
SPECIFIC TO ANY REGION BUT THE
IDEA WOULD BE TO ESTABLISH AN
OFFICE TO ASSIST TRAVELLERS
PEOPLE IN EDUCATION PEOPLE IN
BUSINESS. TO BUSINESS WITH
MEXICO HOW TO NAVIGATE THROUGH.
THE MEXICAN SYSTEM AND THOSE
THOSE ISSUES WE HOPE WILL WILL
BRING US CLOSER TO MEXICO ONE
AND- I THINK I JUST WANNA
COURAGE PEOPLE COMMUNITY TO
CONTINUE TO CALL MY OFFICE
CONTINUE TO CALL US COMMUNICATE
WITH US ABOUT HOW WE CAN DO TO
BETTER SERVE YOU AND HOW WE
WILL WE CAN ACT. TO A FURTHER
THIS DIALOGUE THAT WE'VE
STARTED HERE TODAY AND THAT
IT'S BEEN AN ONGOING DIALOGUE.
STREET YOU KNOW SINCE WE
STARTED THIS COMMITTEE SO A LOT
HAS HAPPENED AND WE HAVE A LOT
TO CELEBRATE BUT THERE'S ALWAYS
MORE WORK TO BE DONE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING DOWN THAT
PATH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
EVERYBODY HAVE A NICE DAY